[Musique]
monsieur bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement Gael Giro je
suis directeur de recherche au CNRS
professeur à Washington à la macroscolo
Storm et directeur fondateur du
programme de justice environnementale de
cette paix université Gilles Ravoux mais
moi je suis enseignant d'économie à
l'Université Paris 8 qui se trouve à
Saint-Denis donc dans le département de
Seine-Saint-Denis et je travaille aussi
comme journaliste économique à Charlie
Hebdo
Raphaël Rousselot
je revendique ma position de banquier
d'affaires de l'économie réelle et
essayiste depuis quelques années
maintenant on a décidé de vous recevoir
tous les trois ce soir
exceptionnellement un dimanche parce que
nos calendriers le pouvez
j'aimerais qu'on parle ce soir d'avenir
de risque de peut-être descente aux
enfers avec la crise financière à quoi
on s'expose
la personne lambda qu'est-ce qu'elle va
ressentir à quoi elle s'expose
Raphaël rousselo qu'est-ce que vous
sentez venir quels sont vos angoisses
est-ce que la tournure que prend les
choses
appelle est optimiste ou pas
alors pour moi on va commencer tout de
suite par poser le décor l'optimisme
pour moi n'est pas la crédulité
l'optimisme c'est comme le disait Anna à
Rennes c'est on se prépare au pire mais
on espère le meilleur
mais c'est dans cet ordre là
et
je crois que c'est un enseignement qui
va être utile alors je suis de plus en
plus schizophrène dans la mesure où le
marché des entreprises moyennes et de
taille intermédiaire ne réalisent pas
encore ou ne veut pas réaliser encore la
profondeur de la situation dans laquelle
nous allons aller
mais ayant vécu moi-même une
demi-douzaine déjà de crise
sans être grand clair je sais que nous
rentrons nous y sommes pas encore nous
rentrons dans une crise et je dirais que
la covid-19 et Vladimir Poutine sont
deux virus qui viennent
cacher la réalité qui devait se réaliser
à un moment ou un autre donc c'est celle
là dont j'aimerais que nous parlions ce
soir parce que voilà on a caché pendant
un certain temps mais la vérité arrive
quel Giroud
moi j'ai beaucoup d'espoir pour la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui en France en
Europe de l'Ouest aux États-Unis celle
que je côtoie en Amérique latine et dans
le même temps je suis obligé de le
reconnaître un peu comme Raphaël que
elle va être exposée à des défis
probablement uniques dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
ce dont il est question aujourd'hui dans
la communauté scientifique un des
climatologues c'est l'extinction
possible de l'humanité au 22e siècle
donc un article qui est sorti dans les
ce qu'on appelle les classes
qui est l'équivalent américain des
crasses en français il compte rendu
l'Académie des sciences où vous avez une
quinzaine de climatologues de premier
plan qui disent malheureusement
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus écarter
l'hypothèse de l'extinction l'humanité
si une série de facteurs aggravants du
réchauffement climatique se conjuguent
de sorte qu'on a la tempête parfaite à
la fin du siècle donc c'est quand même
ça qui est en jeu et donc on est en
train de laisser une planète qui brûle
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire des
sociétés en grande difficulté à une
jeunesse qui pour moi a un courage
impressionnant même si elle est
elle-même traversée évidemment c'est
normal d'angoisse que moi j'ai jamais
connu quand j'avais l'âge de ceux qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça on est le monde on était
plusieurs à se faire la réflexion là on
est le on est le 23 octobre on est en
Île-de-France et là toute la semaine il
a pas fait bon il a fait chaud il a fait
chaud c'est à dire que là cette semaine
l'après-midi on pouvait vraiment se
promener en T-shirt moi j'ai vu des gens
en short enfin c'est et je trouve ça fou
que nous l'humanité enfin tout ce qu'on
a tous créé collectivement on en soit on
se soit volé cette simple expression de
dire il fait beau quand c'est plus on
sait plus qualifier la situation moi
j'ai pas envie de dire qu'il fait beau
je peux dire qu'il fait bon il fait doux
j'ai l'impression que c'est le printemps
j'ai l'impression que les grandes
vacances vont arriver c'est extrêmement
bizarre on a plein je sais que dans le
je crois que c'est dans le Var
actuellement il y a des restrictions sur
la consommation d'eau et on est
mi-octobre c'est vraiment enfin une
perte de repère effectivement qui est
quasi totale
et oui ce que dit Gaël Giraud c'est
juste moi aussi ben voilà moi comme vous
aussi j'enseigne auprès des étudiants
qui sont en master donc ils sont
vraiment dans cet âge je trouve très
intéressant qui est vraiment la fin de
l'insouciance comme dirait notre
président même si les pauvres ça fait
très longtemps qu'ils sont plus
insouciants ne serait-ce que en
Île-de-France par exemple ou ailleurs
avec les attentats qu'ils ont connu en
2015 et qui fait que c'est une
génération qui a vraiment c'est vraiment
fait voler beaucoup de choses en termes
d'insouciance il commence leur vie
adulte et effectivement on leur parle et
moi je leur parle dans dans les cours
comme vous le faites aussi on leur parle
de cataclysme on leur parle de fin du
monde et moi-même donc quand je fais ces
cours-là je n'en reviens pas de ce que
je suis en train de leur dire et c'est
vrai que je me rappelle qu'à l'orage moi
j'étais un gentil étudiant en économie
et ce qui me rendait dingue c'était
l'opposition entre les néoclassiques et
les keynésiens sur la place respective
du marché de l'état où dans les
politiques macroéconomiques et ce qui
est-ce que la dette publique c'est bien
ou pas et c'était tout et j'avais
l'impression déjà qu'on réfléchissait
sur l'avenir du monde et en fait là je
me dis mais c'est une accélération
vertigineuse sur la question de l'eau
pendant
la question de
mentionner ça j'ai une ça vaut la peine
qu'on se redise ensemble que c'est un
sujet qui est cette fois-ci n'est pas
pour le 22e siècle mais pour les deux
décennies qui viennent donc deux choses
là-dessus on a le
wordreferi aux États-Unis qui a fait un
travail sur la vraisemblance d'un manque
d'accès à l'eau potable en Europe de
l'Ouest en 2040 et pour la France on
trouve au moins 20%. donc si on ne fait
rien on perd 20% d'accès à l'eau potable
en France dans moins de 20 ans ce qui
veut dire donc non seulement les
sécheresses qu'on a déjà vont être de
plus en plus sévères mais en plus les
villages où il y a plus d'eau au robinet
pendant l'été ça va être tous les ans en
Italie en Espagne c'est moins 40% voilà
donc là il y a un aspect ça c'est
directement lié au réchauffement
climatique je suis étonné que ce soit
pas un enjeu de sécurité nationale pour
la France aujourd'hui parce que c'est
maintenant que ça se prépare en 2038 il
sera trop tard et puis un deuxième
aspect toujours sur l'eau qui est la
vitesse des infrastructures d'adduction
d'eau potable en milieu rural en France
il y a une dizaine d'années j'ai été
sollicité par Veolia pour travailler sur
un projet de banque de l'eau
en tout cas c'est la propulsion que
j'avais faite avec un bon ami et que
vous connaissez sûrement un grand Jean
puisque Veolia avait besoin de 30
milliards pour rénover des
infrastructures d'adduction d'eau
potable en milieu rurales français qui
aujourd'hui accuse des pertes d'eau en
ligne qui sont absolument phénoménales
donc la provision qu'on avait faite et
que j'ai reprise l'an dernier les
derniers pendant la campagne c'est créer
une banque de l'eau qui finance les 30
milliards et qui se paye elle-même sur
le tarif de l'eau qu'il faut rendre
progressif de manière que les premiers x
m3 soit gratuit et que celui qui change
deux fois c'est un autre sa piscine par
semaine à Nice pas très cher je vois
rien de Ten aujourd'hui dans le
programme du gouvernement et je suis
extrêmement inquiet parce que plus le
temps passe plus ça va être difficile de
rattraper le retard que nous prenons par
rapport à l'accès à l'eau et on peut
vivre sans électricité malheureusement
certains d'entre nous en font
l'expérience en ce moment on peut pas
vivre sans eau
Raphaël j'aimerais qu'on parle j'ai je
voudrais
rebondir sur mes sur mes deux camarades
en fait ma vie professionnelle et sous
le diktat du temps
je te rassure nous aussi
[Rires]
oui mais en fait fondamentalement quand
un entrepreneur me rencontre
ma première question
c'est de combien de temps on dispose
d'abord pour comprendre le problème et
ensuite pour le régler donc étant depuis
plus de 40 ans dans l'obsession de gérer
le facteur temps
je revendique le fait que je suis
extrêmement soucieux du phénomène de
l'eau
mais je pense que l'immédiateté de du
risque social et humain va être plus
rapide que le risque écologique
autrement dit j'ai une forme d'écologie
c'est que
et je pense que Gaëlle va adhérer je ne
connais pas encore Gilles mais va
adhérer à ce principe c'est que
il n'est de richesse que d'hommes pour
moi c'est l'homme qui est au centre de
mon de ma petite croisade en ce moment
et étant au centre je vois les dégâts à
échéance non pas de deux décennies mais
de 2 à 3 ans
sur le décrochage humain que nous avons
organisé et quand je dis le on j'ai été
un contributeur
étant donné que je suis ce que l'on
appelle justement la banquier d'affaires
je vois parfaitement
toute la perversion du du mécanisme qui
permet de régler nos problèmes et en
fait on les règle pas on a créé
simplement un monde artificiel depuis
les années 80 en gros et dans ce monde
artificiel
en fait il y a un saccage de l'être
humain qui devient une simple variable
d'ajustement dans un tableur Excel donc
oui je suis extrêmement soucieux du
phénomène écologique et du problème de
l'eau je dis simplement à nos amis de ce
soir il y a il y a une échéance qui elle
est beaucoup plus
voilà et je j'aimerais qu'on parle de ça
ça me permet de rebondir d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'est pour ça que les
pouvoirs publics à grands coups d'argent
public masque les choses ou essaie de
temporiser les choses pour éviter une
révolte sociale est-ce que l'inflation
en France est contenue à grands coups de
chèques pour éviter que le peuple
français se rebelle et en flamme toute
l'Europe est-ce que le politique est
coincé dans une ambivalence de réalité
et aussi de panique
oui certainement ça joue certainement un
rôle dans la l'inaction de ce
gouvernement actuel et dans le fait que
on se contente d'un bouclier tarifaire
qui d'un côté est trop petit l'Allemagne
met 200 milliards nous on met 24
milliards l'Allemagne c'est pas 10 fois
la France c'est 1,5 fois la France
ça c'est un aspect mais surtout on fait
rien d'autre que le bouclier tarifaire
donc le bouclier tarifaire ne règle rien
sur la question d'inflation
puisqu'en réalité le vrai problème qui
est derrière l'inflation de mon point de
vue c'est d'accès à l'énergie à une
énergie bon marché donc la question pour
la France aujourd'hui c'est d'accélérer
la transition énergétique que ce
gouvernement manifestement ne veut pas
faire même si maintenant il découvre le
vocabulaire de la planification
écologique je me réjouis donc ça c'est
un aspect l'autre aspect c'est je suis
bien d'accord c'est ce que vous disiez
on est en train de créer toutes les
conditions d'une crise sociale
absolument majeure juste un exemple qui
est quand même caricatural ce qui a été
fait par notre actuel première ministre
à l'époque où elle était ministre du
Travail l'an dernier donc la réforme de
Madame borne qui a consisté allongé le
temps d'affiliation nécessaire pour
pouvoir toucher les allocations chômage
alors que nous sortions du confinement
donc on est passé de 4 mois à 6 mois à
un moment où l'essentiel de l'appareil
productif français était en paralysie
ça a plongé immédiatement 600 000
personnes qui auraient dû avoir accès
aux allocations chômage dans l'enfer des
transferts sociaux du RSA qui sont
aujourd'hui en situation de précarité on
a 12 millions de personnes en France qui
sont en situation de précarité
énergétique on a 42000 enfants qui sont
SDF en France alors je me souviens d'un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle je
crois que c'était en 2017 qui avait
promis qu'il y aurait plus de SDF à la
fin de son quinquennat on a 42000
enfants SDF en France aujourd'hui donc
c'est ça la réalité je suis bien
d'accord il y a une bombe sociale qui
est en train de grossir et qui fait
tic-tac tous les jours et en face de ça
effectivement un déni politique qui est
peut-être lié à la panique qui est sans
doute aussi lié à ce que ce que ce que
tu suggirais c'est à dire les
Britanniques sont en grève depuis
plusieurs mois les médias français ne le
disent pas probablement pour avec sa
donne des idées aux Français les
Britanniques n'ont pas du tout la
tradition de la grève française
distress a démissionné c'est pas
uniquement à cause des marchés
financiers qui se sont fâchés c'est
aussi à cause du fait que vous avez des
centaines de milliers de Britanniques
qui sont dans la rue depuis des mois
sans doute que la crainte d'une partie
des autorités européennes c'est que les
Français s'embrassent et que ça donne
des idées à l'ensemble de l'Europe voilà
le gouvernement français aujourd'hui
fait l'autruche par rapport à ces
questions là ne règle rien me
semble-t-il en tout cas pas grand chose
ce qui va générer ce que ce que vous
dites
oui c'est sûr qu'Emmanuel Macron a été
traumatisé par le mouvement des gilets
jaunes je dirais à juste titre puisque
effectivement il s'est passé ça a été le
plus grand mouvement social de la France
même en fait de l'après-guerre parce que
ça a été moi c'est vrai que j'étais
surpris de voir la difficulté qui avait
sa tante de mes collègues journalistes à
appréhender ce mouvement enfin moi je me
suis un tout petit peu promené et les
gens qui ont quand même passé notamment
c'était quand même l'hiver des journées
entières pendant des mois sur des ronds
dans des zones commerciales ou
industrielles hideuses enfin moi je
l'aurais jamais fait moi j'essaye
toujours pour comprendre situation de
mettre à la place des gens de me dire de
la personne qui se lève le matin qui va
aller passer sa journée pour protester
en sachant quand même qui a très peu de
chances qu'il y a des choses au bout et
on sait que ce conflit alors le sel a
vraiment de façon très documentée on
sait que ce conflit a été réglé par la
violence c'est-à-dire qu'on sait que la
solution d'Emmanuel Macron c'était
donner des consignes pour que
effectivement régler de façon violente
les manifestations et je sais pas s'il a
donné des consignes
enfin on sait en tout cas qu'il y a eu
des consignes en tout cas venant en tout
cas du préfet de police de Paris ça
c'est certain sur sur ces troupes pour
pour charger de manière violente les
manifestants dans le but de les dégoûter
ça ça c'est sûr et on sait aussi que on
a une gestion des manifestations ça
c'est aussi très documenté qui a
complètement changé en France ces
dernières années voilà moi j'ai 48 ans
j'ai manifesté pendant des années il y a
tout un tas de manifestations en France
on ne risque rien enfin on savait
comment manifester et on ne risque rien
du côté de la police si on avait un
comportement normal etc maintenant ça
fait déjà vraiment plusieurs années que
les gens ne vont plus manifester que
leurs enfants ou que plein de gens ne
vont plus dans les manifestations parce
qu'ils savent pas s'il rentreront chez
eux ils savent pas dans quel état ils
rentreront donc il y a effectivement
cette colère sociale et moi il y a
quelque chose de cool que je veux
vraiment j'ai du mal à comprendre chez
mes collègues économistes mais aussi
là aussi c'est les journalistes et aussi
chez les politiques c'est que Emmanuel
Macron mène comme une politique
complètement folle vraiment de on
pourrait dire clientéliste au sens
propre du terme c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il achète la paix
sociale de façon très à très court terme
mais vraiment avec notre argent avec
notre argent est-ce que je trouve à les
formes ils sont forts comme au niveau du
gouvernement c'est que c'est des gens
quand c'est la gauche que pouvoir on le
dit toujours l'état ça n'existe pas
c'est l'argent des contribuables et là
vous avez si vous prenez Bruno Le Maire
que ce soit pendant le covid que ce soit
maintenant que ce soit maintenant avec
le la guerre en Ukraine on dit l'état
protège les Français et on sait pas
l'état c'est pas l'état c'est nous et
effectivement il nous protège très mal
et en même temps pour le coup ça coûte
extrêmement cher c'est à dire que il y a
un chiffre qui est sorti les aides
toutes les aides pour l'énergie on est à
peu près à 100 milliards d'euros qui ont
été distribués par l'État par exemple on
la baisse à la pompe il faut quand même
le dire ça bénéficie avant tout au gros
rouleur et contrairement à ce qu'on
croit en fait les gros rouleurs c'est
les hauts revenus il y a cette
mythologie que
de l'ouvrier qui a antenne banlieue qui
fait 50 km tous les jours et tout ça
bien sûr ça existe mais là aussi des
statistiques parce qu'en France il faut
comme le dire on en a pas est
statistique extraordinaire et les gens
qui roulent le plus c'est ceux qui ont
les moyens ça coûte très cher la voiture
et donc quand vous baissez
artificiellement pris à la pompe il y a
vraiment plein d'études qui sont sorties
ça avantage d'être très hauts revenus et
ce qui est ce qui est fou de la part du
gouvernement c'est qu'ils font même pas
semblant d'essayer de récupérer une
partie de ses dépenses alors ça serait
assez facile par une fiscalité
progressive moi il y a un exemple que
j'adore c'est que quand il y a eu le
covid les restaurateurs ont fait des
profits comme jamais dans leur histoire
alors sans travailler bon quand les
aider c'est très bien qu'on a évité les
entreprises enfin très bien mais bon
j'ai dit vraiment très bien j'applaudis
dès demain mais derrière quand on
constate que les gaz ont des profits
anormaux on a récupéré une partie c'est
tout et le fond est un fond monétaire
international a appelé à faire ça l'OCDE
a appelé à faire ça parce qu'ils sont
ils sont pas fous et donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que là une espèce
d'anesthésie juste pour donner un
chiffre le prochain le budget là qui
vient d'être voté pour le budget d'État
pour 2023 nous prévoit un déficit de 150
milliards
et on sait que ça sera plus parce que
les prévisions du budget sont fausses
c'est à dire que par exemple juste pour
donner un exemple le taux d'intérêt sur
la dette à 10 ans le taux d'intérêt
moyen qui a été retenu par Bruno Le
Maire c'est 2,6% par an pardon ça tout
petit peu technique je ferais pas trop
souvent et actuellement si vous allez
aujourd'hui comme je l'ai fait ce matin
sur le site de l'Agence France Trésor
c'est marqué sur la page d'accueil le
taux moyen de la dette à 10 ans en
France il est au-delà de 3%. il est au
delà 3% et donc le budget on est
mi-octobre le budget pour 2023 il est
déjà faux puisque ce taux d'intérêt de
la faire qu'augmenter là évidemment tout
le monde le sait avec certitude donc je
répète le gouvernement s'est permis de
dire le taux d'intérêt sur la dette à 10
ans en France ça à 2,6 en moyenne
aujourd'hui il est déjà à 3% pareil le
gouvernement fait le président
d'inflation qui est sous-estimé il fait
une prévision de croissance c'est
extraordinaire ce document quand vous
regardez le document pour les
journalistes ça s'appelle le plein
emploi les gars ils parlent du plein
emploi c'est quoi voilà on est dans la
misère on sait pas si on arrivera à
chauffer il y a des gens qui ont faim il
y a des gens qui sont sur la rue le
document parle de plein emploi qui est
signé donc par
Attal et le maire enfin ils sont
complètement dans le délire les gars et
donc c'est 150 milliards vont faire
encore exploser notre dette et donc là
on a une dette publique qui devient
complètement folle et qui va être
utilisé demain en termes d'arguments
pour nous dire qu'évidemment ça coûte
trop cher les retraites ça coûte trop
cher le chômage ça coûte trop cher à
l'école ça coûte trop cher la santé et
ce que je ne comprends pas ces chiffres
sont très faciles à voir facile à y
avoir une fronde contre le gouvernement
qui qui nous pille qui nous pille nous
et je sais pas pourquoi on le dit pas
plus que ça tu connais tu connais bien
le surnom de Bruno Le Maire Hermès
vous n'avez pas vu ça
Jupiter c'est notre
Hermès et Son Messager
Raphaël
je
reviens sur deux mots le la
problématique de Macron et la et ce que
Gaëlle évoquait sur le fait que les
jeunes générations se sont celles qui
nous intéressent ce soir la mienne elle
a sa vie derrière donc c'est va être
confronté à quelque chose qui est unique
dans l'histoire de l'humanité et je suis
archi convaincu de ça
je suis passé par la grande maison
à l'époque du 17 avenue Matignon et je
suis parti j'ai filé ma démission en
étant le responsable d'un coup
responsable de la petite activité
chez Rothschild de DPME au moment où
Emmanuel Macron arrive
et en fait
je suis très très heureux très triste tu
auras un plan personnel mais très
heureux d'être passé par ce genre de
grande institutions internationale
parce que
il pêche pour une raison ils ont un
raisonnement qui se veut toujours
cohérent
leur fierté et de ne jamais être pris en
défaut de cohérence pragmatique
cohérence non non justement surtout pas
de pragmatisme et cette cohérence
conceptuelle
ce sont des narcisses de leur pensée
parce qu'ils parce que justement ils
sont tellement fiers rapides dans cette
vision conceptuelle que parler de gros
mots comme le bon sens la réalité comme
un metérologue à qui je dis mais ouvre
la fenêtre pour pour regarder à peu près
le temps qu'il y aura dans une heure non
ça c'est c'est vulgaire c'est c'est
grossiers c'est primaire
et donc l'énorme problème
quand tu te dis mais comment ne
réagissent-ils pas non ils sont enfermés
dans ce dans cette conceptualisation et
donc quand on vient ce qui m'arrive dire
mais vous savez dans tel département tel
type d'activité souffrent pour telle
raison j'ai un argument d'autorité qui
est de dire bon alors là on voit pas du
tout de quoi vous parlez parce que
l'information qui nous remonte ne nous
dit pas ça mais oui bien sûr puisque
l'information que vous allez chercher
c'est celle qui doit conforter votre
concept un peu comme les stations
essence en carafe 20% à 25 % de
différence entre les chiffres du
gouvernement et la réalité et là-dessus
on peut rajouter la concentration des
stations essence en carafe dans un
endroit qui nous amènerait peut-être à
90% des stations en carafe et donc quand
on quand on parle de problématique de
terrain
ma coquetterie de l'économie réelle
c'est que en réalité c'est fini mais de
quoi de quoi tu nous parles puisque ça
fait 40 ans que nous sommes dans une
un concept qui justement ne doit plus
souffrir de la réalité
a été un enjeu décisif pour lui au sens
où il a été pris si je comprends bien
sous la coupe Davis de Rothschild
absolument l'ancien PDG de cette grande
banque et qui en 1981 a été a perdu sa
banque à cause de la nationalisation de
Rothschild donc David de Rothschild est
un homme tout à fait honorable mais qui
a aussi une revanche à prendre sur les
nationalisations 81 et qui lui a un
grand projet on pourrait dire qui vise
la fin des temps qui est la
privatisation absolue du monde et la
médiocratie médiocrinisation si je puis
dire de l'état de manière que un
traumatisme comme les nationalisations
de 80 ne soient plus possibles c'est
attentif c'est une extrapolation c'est
c'est écrit c'est ton point de vue c'est
quoi c'est mon point de vue sur
l'information qui circule à Paris
et donc Emmanuel Macron une certaine
manière et le porte flingue si je puis
dire David de Rothschild donc il est un
petit peu comme les enfants soldats au
Congo c'est les enfants qui sont
capables de tout parler les enfants
soldats au Congo sont les enfants à qui
la première chose qu'on leur demande
c'est d'aller tuer leurs parents pour
être sûr qu'ils ont brûlé tous leurs
vaisseaux et que ils sont prêts à tout
et donc d'une certaine manière je crois
que la personne Emmanuel Macron sur
laquelle on est très très focalisé n'est
pas très intéressant c'est voilà c'est
un garçon qui exécute un programme qui
lui est dicté par d'autres notamment
David de Rothschild et ce programme
c'est la privatisation du monde et la
destruction de l'État social c'est ce
que
j'observeau
voilà on va me dire mais on vient de
nationaliser EDF
la vérité c'est vous avez vu la descente
de Philippe Brun le député PS à Bercy
qui récupère les documents tout à fait
inquiétant dit-il sur ce que le
gouvernement prépare sur EDF quelle est
la visée quel besoin à l'état avait-il
de nationaliser EDF à 100%, alors qu'il
en est déjà 94 % en fait ce qui se cache
derrière très vraisemblablement et les
mois prochains vont nous montrer c'est
un projet de démantèlement def prévu par
le gouvernement pour médiocriser l'État
voilà c'est ça qui est en jeu et
privatiser tout ce qui peut l'être de la
même manière je sais qu'il y a un projet
de démantèlement de la caisse et
dépouillés consignations pour donner le
monopole de la gestion du livret A aux
banques c'est ça quand même la vérité du
programme de ce gouvernement de cette
majorité parce que derrière la
rhétorique sur la planification
écologique et tout ça j'aimerais juste
faire
rebondir et quelque part vous vous posez
justement cette question en fait moi je
suis un enfant
des Lumières
mon père nous a élevé dans ce phénomène
prodigieux de des lumières dont le vrai
libéralisme était l'enfant le
libéralisme de la fin du 18e siècle et
en fait je suis maintenant dans une
véritable guerre contre le
néolibéralisme où on a remplacé des
êtres qui avaient une aspiration une
Vista un enthousiasme un dépassement et
pour des choses qui nous rapprochent une
transcendance de l'être humain
on a remplacé ça par des gestionnaires
le gestionnaire lui il a une feuille et
cette feuille là si on veut justement
l'amener à quelque chose du type du
dépassement il dit mais ça on en a rien
à [__] les mecs moi j'ai une feuille
dans lequel j'ai un axe de temps qui est
de 3 à 5 ans et pendant ces trois à cinq
ans il faut que je remplisse les cases
de cet objectif et je reviens à mon
obsession du facteur temps or on va
crever parce que cette génération à
laquelle nous nous adressons en réalité
c'est pas les trois cinq ans qui
viennent qui les intéressent c'est de
savoir alors qu'ils ont 20 ou 30 ans
qu'est-ce que sera leur vie quand ils
auront 50 ou 60 ans
sur le côté manque de socio perception
de notre élite
d'accord alors juste le truc auquel je
me disais c'est que avec la moi je reste
fasciné effectivement
voilà j'ai eu mon premier téléphone
portable qui était pas du tout un
smartphone à je crois à 35 ans je reste
vraiment fasciné par internet tout ça et
je me disais bon là potentiellement il y
a des gens qui regardent cette émission
n'importe où sur la planète et je me dis
c'est quand même vertigineux de se dire
que nous les français on est là en train
de décrire cette situation cataclysmique
dans ce pays incroyablement riche qui a
été et qui reste une référence au moins
culturelle pour quand même beaucoup de
gens sur la planète
et je me dis que si j'étais dans un pays
réellement pauvre je serais scandalisé
en fait d'entendre d'entendre nos
discussions et donc si jamais il y a
vraiment des jeunes qui nous entendent
c'est vrai que je voudrais juste
rappeler ça que une des grandes
victoires enfin bon là c'est vraiment
que les missions dure très longtemps
mais je l'ai déjà dit ailleurs je pense
que une des grandes victoires des
néolibéraux c'est justement de
revendiquer d'être du côté de la liberté
ça je pense que c'est notre plus grande
défaite que intellectuelle collective à
tous c'est à dire que évidemment que ces
gens-là ne sont pas du côté de la
liberté et que malheureusement c'est
aussi en partie à cause d'une gauche
progressiste qu'on n'arrive plus à
utiliser des termes très simples on voit
très bien on n'arrive pas à dire tout
simplement que Emmanuel Macron est de
droite on le voit très bien dans les
grands débats puis ça n'est pas dit on
n'arrive pas à dire que Emmanuel Macron
est conservateur qu'il est même
réactionnaire sur certains sujets c'est
très c'est très intéressant on continue
à parler de néolibéraux ce qui me paraît
vraiment est une erreur colossale
puisque vous dites que vos adversaires
sont des gens qui défendent la liberté
et donc vous êtes quoi vous vous
critiquez des gens qui défend la liberté
est-ce que des néolibéraux c'est des
gens qui défendent la liberté et donc
vous vous êtes contre la liberté vous
avez perdu et là ce que dit là il y a
rien de neuf puisque Pierre Bourdieu
expliquait ça déjà
exactement dans ces termes-là et donc ce
que je veux rappeler à notre jeunesse
c'est qu'on est effectivement dans un
pays incroyablement riche et que la
grande force de ce camp politique qui
malheureusement a évidemment inclut le
Parti socialiste lorsqu'il était au
pouvoir c'est que de fait que de parler
tout le temps que de déficit public de
trou de la Sécurité sociale de de dette
publique de coûts trop élevés du travail
de manque de compétitivité on a réussi à
s'auto convaincre que on était un pays
mal géré un pays inefficace et quasiment
un pays pauvre ce qui est absolument
sidérant c'est à dire que effectivement
aujourd'hui l'État français est pauvre
ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr mais les
Français sont riches et il y a en fait
beaucoup de Français qui sont vraiment
riches et qui évidemment vont jamais le
dire mais c'est pas c'est pas un
français sur 1000 c'est à dire qu'on a
on a une partie de la population
française qui est réellement riche on
est dans un pays qui est riche et donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que
ce qui est fou et je pense que c'est
comme ce que perçoivent plein de gens
c'est que si on si on raisonne si on
regarde l'économie française un peu en
haut comme on peut le faire dans un
cours dans un cours au lycée à
l'université ou même au collège parce
que c'est très simple finalement ce que
je raconte on a les moyens scientifiques
techniques et économiques de résoudre
tous nos problèmes mais je dirais même
très largement c'est ça que je veux
rappeler c'est à dire que c'est bien ça
aussi qui rend dingue tout un tas de
gens c'est que voilà isoler tous les
bâtiments en France mais c'est rien du
tout réduire massivement la consommation
d'énergie ça n'est rien du tout alors je
veux dire c'est rien du tout que ça
quand même non mais c'est peut-être
compliqué politiquement et tout ça mais
en tout cas ni techniquement ni
financièrement ça ne pose aucun alors là
vraiment ça là vraiment je me permets
d'affirmer ça sans aucune nuance c'est
juste que on a perdu tous les moyens et
on a revendiqué notamment avec la
funeste construction européenne si mal
nommée on a revendiqué le fait de perdre
tous les moyens de maîtrise de notre
destin
c'est ça c'est ça le problème
sur la question de la transition
énergétique juste sur cette question qui
est un aspect de la crise écologique et
la réponse qu'on peut lui apporter
donc merci tu Russo dont je préside à
sortir un rapport en mars dernier qui
décrit un scénario complet de
décarbonation de l'économie française
d'aujourd'hui à 2050 de manière à
honorer nos engagements qui sont la
neutralité carbonée de la France en 2050
donc le scénario est entièrement écrit
si jamais le gouvernement voulait s'y
intéresser à mon avis il aurait raison
ce serait une bonne idée les grandes
étapes sont bien connues tu t'y a fait à
l'usurant instant c'est la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments tous les
bâtiments la mobilité verte la mobilité
verte ça passe par le train ça passe pas
par la voiture électrique et il y a eu
juste hier une tribune dans Le Monde
d'un certain nombre de présidents de
région qui sont très favorables à un
grignotil ferroviaire c'est-à-dire qu'en
France on avait 50000 km de voies
ferrées après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
on en a plus 25000 aujourd'hui donc il
faut réhabiliter toutes nos charmantes
petites gares dans la Creuse ils sont
absolument délicieux de veut dire que la
plupart des français n'est pas besoin de
prendre la voiture pour se déplacer 90%
des Français vivent à 10 km d'une d'une
gare routière d'une gare ferroviaire et
puis troisième étape évidemment qu'il a
pu compliquer mais qu'on peut faire tu
as bien raison on n'a pas besoin de
résoudre le problème de l'unification
quantique avec la relativité c'est c'est
le verdissement de l'industrie et de
l'agriculture combien ça coûte parce que
ce que tu disais c'est pas c'est pas un
problème financier et tu réagissais
combien ça coûte nous ce qu'on a chiffré
c'est alors chaque année ça coûte un peu
plus de 120 milliards d'euros mais là
dedans il y a une partie d'argent qui
réorientée dans la bonne direction parce
qu'on va peut-être y revenir une partie
de l'argent aujourd'hui malheureusement
pas dans les marchés financiers ne sert
à rien pour l'économie réelle on va y
revenir je suppose donc en net ça coûte
2% du PIB français chaque année
d'aujourd'hui à 2050 2% c'est tout à
fait jouable aujourd'hui je suis bien
d'accord donc c'est ça à mon avis que
Gilles veut dire et c'est ça qu'il faut
préciser
on a les chiffres on a le scénario le
gouvernement découvre la planification
écologique il suffit de mettre en oeuvre
ce que l'Institut Rousseau a proposé
vous aurez aussi juste un tout petit peu
prendre du recul par rapport à ce que
disait mon voisin de droite Raphaël sur
la question libéralisme et je suis
entièrement d'accord c'est ce que
j'essaie de dire un petit peu dans le
livre que je viens de publier un composé
un monde en commun au fond on pourrait
caractériser le libéralisme des lumières
un de la haute clairon au 18e avec trois
aspects à mon avis trois trois piliers
fondamentaux le premier c'est la liberté
et c'est la désacralisation du pouvoir
nous les français on a coupé la tête du
roi ce qui était une manière de dire on
ne veut plus idolâtrer le corps du roi
ce qu'on s'est remis à faire dans un
espèce de délire messianique en 2017
voilà et ça n'est plus ni à l'église ni
à l'histoire ni à la tradition ni même
aux lois des reins du matérialisme
dialectique chez les marxistes de nous
dire ce qu'on a fait en société on va en
parler ensemble et on est assez grande
pour en discuter ensemble et ça non ça
s'appelle la démocratie donc ça c'est la
liberté deuxièmement l'État de droit et
ça c'est Montesquieu l'esprit des lois
la séparation des pouvoirs qui est
complètement bafoué aujourd'hui en
France regardez ce qui se passe avec la
justice la séparation des pouvoirs et
l'égalité de tous devant la loi qui est
également bafoué puisque une partie
d'entre nous pratique de l'évasion
fiscale de manière systématique c'est ce
que le président de la République
appelle l'optimisation fiscale
et ça c'est l'égalité égalité devant la
loi et puis troisièmement à l'époque nos
révolutionnaires libéraux sacralise la
propriété privée puisqu'elle devient un
droit sacré et inviolable dans la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme moi
mon diagnostic et c'est un peu c'est un
peu j'ai rejoint complètement ce que tu
disais Raphaël c'est à dire le
néolibéralisme à mon avis on appelle à
tort néolibéralisme et en fait c'est un
poste libéralisme c'est le fossoyeur de
libéralisme et je crois que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec l'actuel
gouvernement c'est l'acte de mort le
libéralisme à la française en tout cas à
l'européenne façon 18e siècle qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait il a resacralisé les
marchés financiers le pouvoir en mettant
les marchés financiers à la place de
Dieu
si vous réfléchissez une seconde à la
Vulgate qui tourne autour des marchés
financiers ils sont
omnipotent alors on se demande est-ce
qu'on peut faire ça mais non on est dans
les marchés financiers vont se fâcher
c'est les nouveaux dieux païens qui à
qui il faut en fait livrer de temps en
temps les jeunes filles pour qu'il soit
content et qu'une dévore pas la totalité
de la population donc ça ça c'est la
très mauvaise théologie c'est du
paganisme
dans lequel avec lequel on a renoué
aujourd'hui et en fait en obligeant les
États à se re-financer auprès des
marchés financiers ce qu'on n'avait pas
fait du tout avec les circuit du trésor
de bloc lunaire pendant pendant plus
d'une génération est-ce qu'il y a très
très bien fonctionné en fait on met les
marchés financiers au-dessus des états
et on donne au marché financiers le
droit de nous dire quel type de
politique publique on peut mettre en
œuvre même chose avec la clause de
défense des investisseurs la fameuse
traité sur la charte de l'énergie les
fameux traités commerciaux bilatéraux ou
on est en train de dire mais des
investisseurs privés vont pouvoir faire
un procès à un État souverain si cet
état met en oeuvre des un certain nombre
de lois qui sont défavorables aux
intérêts d'investisseurs et comment
est-ce qu'on va régler différents dans
les tribunaux d'arbitrage internationaux
dont on sait à l'avance qui vont arbitré
en faveur des intérêts privés voilà donc
ça c'est premièrement on a resalé le
pouvoir en mettant les marchés
financiers à la place du corps du roi
deuxièmement
on va vous entendre là-dessus mais donc
l'état de droit de mon point de mon
point de vue aujourd'hui en France n'est
plus respecté
est tordu en faveur de la défense des
intérêts d'un tout petit nombre donc on
a perdu complètement le principe
républicain de l'égalité devant la loi
et troisièmement on absolutise la
propriété privée et on essaie de tout
privatiser ce que disait tout à l'heure
depuis alors il savait qu'il y a un
autre projet aussi que de privatisation
des routes nationales en France donc
peut-être que si on laisse ce
gouvernement avancé on va avoir des
péages en route nationale voilà donc
c'est ça le donc c'est ça le poste
libéralisme je suis alors 100% d'accord
mais 100% il n'y a pas il y a pas une
feuille de papier à cigarette de
différence entre nous deux j'ajouterai
un élément c'est que dans cette
aspiration libérale il y a eu un outil
je parle souvent de ma trousse à outils
et dans cette trousse à outils il y
avait la rémunération du capital et le
capitalisme tirait une certaine forme de
légitimité
du fait que
la rémunération qu'il avait je pense à
l'âge d'or entre la fin de la guerre des
guerres napoléoniennes et 1914 à prendre
pendant à peu près 100 ans la
rémunération du capital était
proportionnelle à la prise de risque
et je veux attirer nos auditeurs ce soir
sur un point très pratique c'est que si
cette génération
n'obtient pas par voie de volts ou de
manifestations violentes dans la rue que
la rémunération du capital
redevienne proportionnelle à la prise de
risque qu'est-ce qui se passe depuis 40
ans c'est que nous avons
contribué à un système
c'est que on n'est plus dans la
production de richesse de biens et de
services marchands etc
qu'on peut critiquer mais voilà on avait
une base et aujourd'hui mon industrie et
toute l'accord de gens qui tournent
autour sont paraît-il des créateurs de
valeurs
et ce mot est diabolique au sens où je
pense que le malin se pour lèche les
babines il doit être dans un état mais
jubilatoire le mec aujourd'hui parce que
cette rémunération qui est décorée
maintenant de la production de de bien
et de richesse nous est imposé là encore
je reviens à cette notion de concept par
une sorte de Dius ex machina dont on
sait pas d'où il vient mais qui fait que
quand je suis à Bercy pour sauver une
boîte qui emploie 1400 ouvriers en
France et qui est dans la mécanique et
qui a fait tout ce qu'il faut en termes
de d'automatisation de digitalisation
etc mais la mécanique ne peut pas
dégager plus de en inflation 4% de
rendement sur le capital quand je dis ça
au cinquième étage à l'étage des
cabinets on me dit ah oui je dis mais
vous avez
qui venait de le doter d'un milliard moi
je vous demande 10 12 millions pour
vraiment continuer d'avoir ces 1400
personnes qui travaillent
retour au bout d'un mois ah oui mais on
peut pas parce que Bruxelles nous
retoquerait comme quoi on
subventionnerait en axe on acceptant que
ces fonds nous soient prêtés à 4% ou à
5%
ce serait du subventionnement mais
arrêtez les mecs c'est pas du
subventionnellement c'est la nécessité
de trouver la rémunération du capital
qui est proportionnelle à la prise de
risque or cette société spécifiquement
et si son président mon regard il va
être réjoui a été obligé de s'endetter
pour créer du levier sur le rendement et
se retrouve dans une procédure
collective parce qu'elle ne peut pas
rembourser la dette privée qui avait
permis de doper le rendement mais
attendez mais il est pas le seul à faire
ça malheureusement
donc effectivement
sur le problème de la sacralisation on
est dans le paganisme de du veau d'or
mais en sachant que ce vendeur
demande un rendement qui n'est pas
compatible avec l'économie réelle et là
on est on est sur du dur
le veau d'or le paganisme le dur
non c'est vrai que c'est
c'est vraiment une histoire très
curieuse et c'est vrai que je pense que
là malheureusement ça a vraiment abîmé
la démocratie c'est que un chat vas-y
oui non non mais c'est que si on essaye
juste simplement d'essayer de parce que
moi donc
ces dernières années notamment par mon
travail de journaliste économique je me
rends compte que tout simplement pour
dire les choses dans les discussions au
sein de la rédaction de Charlie Hebdo
c'est-à-dire je me rends compte que je
me retrouve avec des gens qui sont très
cultivés des gens qui connaissent la
littérature qui connaissent l'histoire
et tout ça et je vois qu'effectivement
ils connaissent pas du tout les
mécanismes économiques et en discutant
avec mes étudiants en discutant en
participant des conférences je me rends
compte que vraiment le fait que
simplement les institutions économiques
de base que le vraiment des choses très
très basiques ne soient pas partie du
cursus obligatoire des collégiens des
lycéens ça s'impose ça pose un énorme
problème et donc ce qui est très curieux
c'est que des choses que finalement des
gens comme on nage ou encore plus
d'expérience ont vécu ne sont pas
enseignés de façon tranquille voilà des
défaits qui sont connus et donc il y a
l'impression que tous nos échappent
alors que c'est vrai que
l'idée qui s'expliquait déjà par exemple
surprend par exemple dans les dans les
années 1980 évidemment ça commence à
dater un peu donc il y a à peu près 40
ans toujours mes chers amis du Parti
socialiste saut au pouvoir et vont
procéder à la plus grande libéralisation
de la Bourse de Paris des marchés
financiers déjà au nom à l'époque du
financement de la dette publique l'idée
dans de rendre la Bourse de Paris
attractive pour les investisseurs
financiers et moi il y a un économiste
que j'aime beaucoup et là aussi vous
voyez c'est intéressant qui s'appelle
Danny Rodrick
c'est pas la peine de le dire donc il
s'appelle Dany Rodrigue et professeur
Harvard et est vraiment donc c'est je le
donne à lire à mes étudiants tous les
ans depuis quelques années et il se
moque de moi parce que je le vénère
quasiment ça puisque c'est très
religieux ce soir donc Saint-Denis et
donc ce qui est marrant quand même c'est
donc ce gars-là donc il est prof à la
Kennedy cool qui est l'équivalent de
Sciences Po Paris mais
c'est ça
la taille américaine comparable et donc
c'est l'école en fait c'est très
intéressant c'est l'école qui forme les
futurs aux fonctionnaires et les futurs
ministres du monde entier c'est-à-dire
que là vous avez fait partie des écoles
dans le monde où vous avez des gens qui
viennent d'Asie qui viennent d'Afrique
ils viennent d'Europe et qui viennent se
former qui viennent apprendre vraiment
les meilleures choses pour ensuite
retourner dans leur pays et mettre en
oeuvre tout un tas de politiques et donc
ce gars là il est prof là je la Sallé
légitimité c'est quand même très
difficile au dessus c'est prix Nobel si
vous voulez quasiment il est juste en
dessous qui ne veut rien dire en terme
de légitimité au sein de nous notre
communauté un peu bizarre des on est
alors là bon ça regretter Bernard Marie
s'expliquer tout le temps c'est sûr que
paix à son âme s'il y a bien une
discipline ou le vocabulaire religieux
marche hyper bien c'est bien la science
économique avec les grands prêtres que
sont les prix Nobels ça a déjà été
expliqué 50 fois plus bien d'ailleurs
pourquoi on utilise ce type de vocable
hein continuez juste ma petite truc et
donc dernier Rodrigue explique quand
même très tranquillement depuis des
années pour moi c'est le meilleur
économiste au sein de la profession
légitime de la mondialisation vers c'est
très intéressant parce qu'en fait il est
né en Turquie ensuite il a pris
nationalité américaine et donc il
raconte quand il raconte un tout petit
peu sa vie ce qui fait pas souvent que
il a vu son père en fait qui avait une
petite une toute petite entreprise
bénéficier de mesures protectionnistes
qui avait été prise à ce moment-là et
donc ça l'avait fait réfléchir et c'est
un truc qu'il avait gardé en tête il se
retrouve aux États-Unis tous ses
collègues sont à fond pour le
libre-échange et lui qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il regarde la réalité et regarde la
réalité dans le monde entier
c'est-à-dire qu'il s'intéresse aussi
vraiment à l'Afrique vraiment à
l'Amérique latine vraiment à l'Asie
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui pense la
mondialisation
pas juste comme un américain mais comme
quelqu'un qui réfléchit à l'ensemble de
la planète et ce qui démontre et moi
pour moi vraiment le sens ça plaira à
Gael Giraud sans se mathématique du
terme c'est qu'il montre que ce que tout
le monde sait finalement mais que la
mondialisation sans aucune règle mine la
démocratie qui montre qu'en fait il y a
un conflit il y a un conflit entre la
mondialisation sans aucune règle et la
démocratie et ce qui est rigolo ou pas
pour mes étudiants c'est qu'il dit le
pire endroit de ce point de vue là c'est
l'Union européenne parce que l'Union
européenne c'est un endroit où la
mondialisation est la plus totale
puisque c'est l'endroit parmi les pays
riches où les États se sont le plus des
saisies de leur souveraineté et
effectivement là aussi Emmanuel Macron
vient de s'en rendre compte puisque
lundi il a fait un entretien aux échos
et où il dit cette phrase ahurissante de
naïveté lui dit les Américains
soutiennent l'industrie américaine bravo
Emmanuel les Chinois soutiennent
l'industrie chinoise bravo Emmanuel et
nous les Européens il faut que nous
soutenions l'industrie européenne ce qui
ne veut rien dire ce qui ne variance que
l'industrie européenne en fait ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas et ça
n'existera jamais puisque l'Union
européenne était bâtie sur le fait de
sur une lutte à mort entre les
entreprises de continents européens et
quand il y a eu des toutes petites
tentatives de créer des champions
européens la Cour de justice qui
effectivement de façon fort logique a
mis en œuvre les traités européens à
interdit toute création et c'est pour ça
qu'on a aucun géant européen dont à peu
près rien ni évidemment dans la
formation ni dans nouvelle technologie
ni dans l'automobile on est à la ramasse
dans tous les domaines et en fait ça ça
a été une volonté
mise en oeuvre au nom de cette folie de
la concurrence et donc Danny Rodrick
nous dit nous dit clairement depuis les
années 90 les dirigeants des pays
occidentaux ce sont en fait adressés à
l'extérieur et là effectivement Emmanuel
Macron est caricatural de ce point de
vue là il le revendique c'est-à-dire que
par exemple pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait
la réforme des retraites Emmanuel Macron
il le dit très clairement c'est un
signal c'est le vocabulaire qui est
utilisé qui est envoyé à la commission
européenne à la communauté financière
mondiale au fameux marché financier
mondiaux et donc il revendique le fait
de qu'en fait les gens qui s'intéressent
et ces gens là et que en fait nous
effectivement on va être effectivement
être sacrifié pour envoyer le bon signal
à ces trucs là et donc je trouve ça fort
que maintenant il y a plein plein de
travaux enfin c'est ça c'est très
curieux on sait maintenant y compris je
veux dire dans la recherche entre
guillemets que il y a ce conflit
absolument dingue et on voit bon ce qui
se passe en Italie on voit ce qui se
passe en Suède c'est extrême droite qui
progresse partout on a eu Trump le
brexit et à chaque fois à chaque fois il
y a plusieurs éléments mais un des
éléments majeurs c'est des gens en fait
ce monde complètement dérégulé soit
disant ouvert en fait on n'en veut pas
on en a jamais voulu on n'a jamais voté
pour et ça nous a été imposé est-ce que
tu peux donner la parole à Gaëlle s'il
te plaît oui
je souhaiterais que vous répondiez juste
pour aller de nouveau dans ton sens et
cranter un pas de plus
l'inculture économique c'est pas
simplement nous tous les citoyens c'est
aussi les économistes eux-mêmes
professionnels alors je donne un exemple
très simple sur les marchés financiers
en fait ce qu'on enseigne à l'université
ce que j'ai enseigné moi pendant des
années c'est les marchés financiers
complets dans lesquels prétendument il
est possible pour tous les investisseurs
de se protéger contre toute forme de
risque je peux me rédiger pour parler de
vocabulaire technique contre toute forme
de risque on sait très bien que ça n'est
jamais le cas en réalité tous les
marchés sont incomplets il y a plein de
risques face auxquels il est impossible
de se protéger voilà or la théorie
économique la plus orthodoxe et ça c'est
un vocabulaire religieux la théorie
économique la plus orthodoxe qu'on
appelle la théorie d'équilibre général
dans les années 80 en 1986 deux
collègues que j'aime beaucoup deux amis
de grands messieurs de la théorie des
clinique générale John genacoplast
université Yale et héracliste pour les
marchés acquises université de Brown à
l'époque démontre que les marchés
financiers incomplets sont toujours très
inefficaces la démonstration est
technique vous pouvez la retrouver sur
internet si ça vous amuse il y a un peu
de maths dedans
pas mal de nos collègues sont incapables
de l'enseigner alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
font une enseigne que le cas marcher
complet et ils me disent alors je leur
demande mais et les marchés incomplet
vous avez regardé ah non non c'est un
peu technique c'est un peu dur pour mes
étudiants puis on le fera l'année
prochaine et donc on enseigne à nos
étudiants avec des marchés complets que
la main visible est très efficace et on
oublie on oublie de leur dire qu'avec
des marchés incomplets c'est à dire dans
le monde réel la main invisible n'existe
pas elle est invisible parce qu'elle
n'existe pas et que on a la
démonstration y compris du côté pas des
marxistes chevelu barbuses de l'économie
néoclassique la plus stricte que les
marchés financiers sont toujours très
inefficaces et on sait ça depuis 1986
voilà la difficulté c'est qu'une partie
de nos collègues ne savent pas ça ne
l'enseigne pas en partie parce qu'il
ignore eux-mêmes ou quand il le savent
d'un geste pudique reporte ça l'année
suivante et chaque année c'est reporté à
l'année suivante de sorte que nos
étudiants n'apprennent jamais je bois du
lait sur cette notion effectivement de
la complétude et de l'inéficience qui
est totalement
parce qu'elle les méconnue ou mal connue
elle aimait prisée elle est marginalisée
mais je reviens sur ce que tu disais
j'ai
sur l'arrivée de la gauche en 80 et de
ce que j'ai vécu par un oncle interposé
à New York du Bérégovoy est faite
[Musique]
et effectivement quand
cet homme qui venait du monde industriel
par je dirais par sa sagesse son
raisonnement son basse son bon sens
était arrivé au plus haute
responsabilités
à New York pour justement rendre visite
à la bourse de américaine
donc je dirais à son point de départ il
est quand même assez hostile à ce qu'il
allait visiter et il a rencontré un
certain nombre d'hommes dont un que je
connaissais intimement
qui lui vend le fait que la Bourse
américaine est en fait l'émanation
populaire du népargne qui est organisée
via des fonds de pension et en disant
vous vous avez un système un petit peu
obsolète
et nous on est quand même beaucoup plus
sophistiqué il y a d'ailleurs des
papiers de la Banque mondiale sur le la
problématique de la sophistication que
qu'apporte effectivement les fonds de
pension
de remarque la première c'est que
que l'on soit par un fond de portion ou
que l'on soit en retraites par
répartition
la responsabilité de payer le retraité
repose toujours sur l'être humain qui
soit doit permettre de payer des
dividendes soit de payer une cotisation
donc de toute façon c'est c'est un
leurre de croire parce que ça revient
toujours à l'être humain d'accord qui
doit payer pour ses aînés ça c'est la
première petite parenthèse la deuxième
c'est que effectivement
on a rendu
la finance qui elle est très
mathématique
on a donné ce sentiment que la noblesse
conceptuelle de l'économie était dans
les mathématiques et on a
justement rendu légitime le diktat
des instruits et on le voit notamment
par ce phénomène de migration
extraordinaire des grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs vers le monde de la finance
dans les années post Bérégovoy Effects
et je suis absolument stupéfait de voir
que mes camarades sur le plan
générationnel c'est un les papilles
boomers ont été aspirés par justement ce
phénomène financier plutôt que de
s'intéresser à construire des ponts des
tunnels des médicaments
ou des scanners ils étaient et on est
arrivé à une forme d'élitisme
ou tu as un écosystème que je côtoie
dans lequel tu as les investisseurs les
banquiers d'affaires les avocats
d'affaires les comptables de de toute la
comptabilité des
transactions
la communication financière etc et tu es
là dans un entre soi
mondialisé qui lui considère que la
vraie liberté elle est elle est
matérielle je te coupe
également est-ce que les fous ont pris
le contrôle de l'asile
est-ce que quand on a cette déconnexion
totale entre la réalité et il a la
théorie des facto bien sûr qu'ils ont
bien sûr et c'est là où c'est
extrêmement difficile et ma vraie
inquiétude j'ai une espérance mais ma
vraie inquiétude elle est sur le fait
que tu ne peux pas avoir un dialogue
avec ces gens-là qui te disent mais non
ma théorie est parfaite je te coupe je
vous coupe je vous redistribuer la
parole
est-ce que maintenant qu'on a ce monstre
qu'il a depuis 40 ou 50 ans qui a pris
une vitesse une masse un inertie
tellement importante que les politiques
sont condamnés à courir derrière sous
peine que cette énorme dinosaure
monstrueux
trébuche et nous emmène par le fond nous
emmène par le fond parce que on est dans
un système over stretch hypertendu et
que si une petite corde de ce système
pète toutes les autres vont péter en
même temps est-ce que le phénomène de
guerre le phénomène de covid le
phénomène de réchauffement climatique
mais encore plus ce système sous tension
et que comme on n'a pas su le régulateur
correctement
on est coincé et on va être obligé de
passer par un événement exotique
douloureux pour remettre les choses à
plat qui va laisser énormément
d'entreprises et de personnes privées
sur le carreau dans la plus grande
précarité le plus
juste avant juste avant
je le redoute
je le redoute parce que
je vois encore à dormir avec ça
c'est difficilement assez difficilement
parce que je pense à tous les jeunes qui
m'entourent et ça me soucie et ceux que
j'ai laissé à Nantes à l'heure du
déjeuner oui ça me soucie parce
qu'effectivement ils ont des ils ont des
gamins etc juste un mot c'est que
je ne vois pas comment on pourrait
éviter
cet épisode de chaos
parce que pour la première fois la dette
la dette globale quand je parle de la
dette je parle toujours de la dette
globale privée plus publique privée plus
public d'accord qui représente 300 % du
PIB de la planète pour donner les ordres
les ordres de grandeur mais cette dette
globale qui est la nourriture de toute
l'industrie financière il n'y a pas
d'industrie financière s'il n'y a pas de
levier c'est clair or à partir du moment
où elle a été à l'origine du problème et
qui est de mon point de vue elle ne peut
plus être la solution qu'elle a été
depuis 35 ans
c'est que nous n'avons plus l'outil
l'outil on va dire keynésien etc juste
un chiffre il faut aujourd'hui 2 %
d'augmentation de la dette publique pour
générer 1% de croissance en gros en
Occident donc il faut 8 dollars injecter
pour un dollar restitué alors si on est
en date globale oui on est peut-être
dans ces ordres là mais moi je crois
Raphaël que un ce qu'il faut surtout
dire en réponse à la fragile à la
question et c'est que en réalité c'est
pas un destin c'est à dire
malheureusement effectivement au risque
d'avoir un crack financier et la hausse
des taux des banques centrales est une à
mon avis une très mauvaise idée une très
mauvaise réponse à l'inflation qui
risque d'accélérer et de précipiter le
crack mais en réalité on pourrait très
bien éviter tout ça on peut très bien
réguler les marchés financiers parce que
on a cette idée que ce monstre est
maintenant omnipotent on peut rien faire
c'est pas vrai
les grandes étapes de la réagulation
sont bien connues en France on sépare
les banques de dépôt de crédit les
banques traditionnelles tu vas
travailler des banques de marché qui
font la spéculation sur le marché
financiers
une fausse loi de séparation bancaire
qui a été écrite par BNP paribel la
Société Générale pour que ça ne sépare
pas il y a des sources oui je peux pas
les citer mais oui effectivement BNP la
Société Générale sont allés à Bercy leur
expliquer écouter les amis on est un peu
plus fort que vous on vous a écrit la
loi les sources de ceux qui se souvient
merci pour leur expliquer bien sûr ils
font le siège de Bercy en permanence il
y a un livre de Laurent
Karine berger et Pierre boscovici on
fait passer cette loi qui est une loi
scélérate qui fait le contraire parce
qu'elle prétend faire donc le préambule
de la loi dit il faut séparer la loi de
sépare pas ce qui a été reconnu par
Frédéric oudeal PDG de la Société
générale devant le Parlement devant
l'Assemblée nationale
qui a dit les amis cette loi m'oblige à
filialiser fidéliser c'est pas séparés
1,5 % des activités de marché et quand
il a vu qu'il avait fait une grosse
bêtise évidemment c'est pas exactement
ce que je voulais dire mais en fait
c'est la réalité donc cette loi en fait
il faut revenir sur cette loi à l'époque
j'avais préparé le paragraphe qui va
bien il y a un paragraphe à changer pour
séparer vraiment une fois qu'on a séparé
on a mis fin au chantage des mégabongs
systémiques françaises sur l'état qui ne
cesse de dire à l'état vous ne pouvez
rien faire contre nous parce que si on
meurt vous mourrez avec nous pourquoi
parce que ces banques sont tellement
grosses qu'aujourd'hui si BNP Société
Générale BPCE ou le Crédit Agricole
faisait faillite l'État n'est pas
capable d'assurer la garantie publique
sur les comptes de dépôt à hauteur de
100.000 euros par contre c'est 72000 non
par contre et par un établissement non
ça a pas de glissement
m'avait dit qu'il était il avait préparé
un dispositif de levier en engageant la
France
je te donne un exemple rien que pour le
système bancaire chypriote en
qui fait naufrage en 2010 Chypre c'est
tout petit on se pose la question de
savoir si Chypre va réussir à tenir la
garantie publique sur les comptes de
dépôt des chipriotes ce qui est rien du
tout donc à fortiori pour la France sur
un monstre comme BNP Paribas c'est clair
qu'on ne peut pas l'état français ne
pourra pas le faire et donc on imagine
ce que ça va représenter pour les
français si il perdent leur compte de
dépôt tout simplement parce que BNP a
fait de la spéculation sur le marché
financier au passage j'ouvre une
parenthèse donc ou une autre banque au
passage
c'est la raison fondamentale pour
laquelle nos amis banquiers sont aussi
favorables à la monnaie digitale
l'avantage de la monnaie digitale c'est
que le jour où la toute la monnaie
devient digitale plus personne ne peut
aller planquer ses économies sous son
matelas
exactement et donc plus de problèmes
liés à cette question on peut faire
faillite et les gens ne peuvent plus
retirer leur argent dans le camp de
dépôt avant que la banque est faite
c'est impossible je referme cette
parenthèse donc la première étape c'est
la séparation des banques deuxième étape
il faut reréguler les marchés financiers
et on sait très bien ce qu'il faut faire
je l'ai expliqué
des dizaines de fois notamment dans mon
bouquin elle va propositions pourraient
faire mes capitalisme mettre fin au
Havre fréquence trading le trading out
fréquence ou ce sont des logiciels qui
font du trading un million de fois par
seconde ce qui n'a aucun sens économique
que la valeur d'un titre économique ne
change pas un million de fois par
seconde aujourd'hui la moitié des
transactions financières en Europe et
aux États-Unis se font par les Africains
alors c'est plus aux États-Unis c'est
75% des États-Unis en Europe c'est la
moitié
il faut il faut juste faire ça c'est
tout ça n'a aucune valeur sociale aucune
utilité troisième étape je vais laisser
la parole à Gilles troisième étape il
faut sécuriser des champs de
compensation donc c'est un sujet mal
connu nous expliquer un petit peu la
Commission européenne malheureusement a
mis en place la directive émir qui a mis
en concurrence les champs de
compensation une chambre de
compréhension c'est quoi on en a tous
entendu parler Yoro clé stream en Europe
c'est un organisme international qui
centralise des transactions financières
entre grandes institutions grandes
institutions financières au niveau
internationales donc si par exemple la
somme gêne veut transacter avec Morgan
stalle aux États-Unis elle passe par une
chambre de condensation qui vérifie que
la transaction se fait bien et que la
chambre de compensation prélève toute
petite marge d'ailleurs on pourrait le
faire pour l'État au passage ça
s'appelle la taxe Tobin et par ailleurs
elle-même est supposée avoir une espèce
d'airbag financier avec la marge qu'elle
prélève pour au cas où une des
contreparties ferait faillite rembourser
l'autre donc elle sert aussi de
compagnie d'assurance implicite dans une
transactions internationales en les
mettant en concurrence les unes contre
les autres qu'a fait malheureusement la
directive émir les chambres de
compensation ont réduit leur marge on
réduit le coussin donc l'airbag et
aujourd'hui si on avait un gros
établissement financier qui faisait
faillite les champs ne sont pas sur
elle-même feraient probablement faillite
donc effet domino donc effet domino sur
la totalité de la planète donc il faut
remettre les charmes de compensation
sous tutelle publique international et
cesser de mettre en concurrence comme on
l'a fait donc les grandes étapes sont
connues on peut maîtriser le monstre si
on veut le faire et moi on m'a servi des
origines je te donne la parole tout de
suite après mon ma servi que
Balin balle de balle 3
vous avez des fonds propres tout allait
bien
donc on pourra reparler les balles 3
demandes simplement 3% de fonds propres
par rapport à la taille du bilan donc le
fond propre pour ceux qui voient pas ce
que c'est là aussi l'airbag de la banque
dans le cas d'une banque dans lequel la
banque est supposée piocher dans le cas
où elle-même fait des grosses pertes sur
ses actifs aujourd'hui ces 3% c'est très
insuffisant c'est calculer avec des
modèles qui sont utilisés par les
banquiers que j'ai fait moi-même parce
que j'étais contre les marchés
financiers qui qui tordent complètement
la réalité des risques auxquels font
face les banques pour minimiser les
appels de en capitaux de fonds propres
que les banques vont devoir réaliser
donc c'est très insuffisant au début du
20e siècle on était à 20% je pense que
c'est le bon niveau et c'est pas du tout
une position de gauchiste de dire ça
vous avez un grand économiste allemand
tout à fait libéral Martin Helvy qui a
publié un papier un bouquin d'ailleurs
avec une prof de Harvard pour dire il
faut 20% pour les banques évidemment les
banques hurles en disant oh là là mais
si on fait ça
on pourra plus faire du crédit à
l'économie réelle elles en font déjà pas
beaucoup et deuxièmement et voilà et
deuxièmement c'est le contraire plus la
banque est sûre parce qu'elle a des
fonds propres élevés plus elle peut
prendre des risques vous avez des
colonies réelles et donc plus elle va
prêter exactement le contraire de ce que
raconte les banquiers voilà donc ça
aussi on peut très bien le faire on peut
réécrire balle 3 que de toutes les
manières il faut réécrire pour
introduire du verre dans la comptabilité
des banques par exemple mettre un
facteur pénalisant lorsque les banques
font des crédits bruns et un facteur
favorisant lorsqu'elles font du crédit
vert donc de façon la réécriture de
balle 3 est déjà en chantier ça
s'appelle Balka revers voilà et au
passage il faut en profiter pour
rehausser les exigences de capital donc
nous font propres pour toutes les
banques
merci beaucoup messieurs oui alors pour
revenir simplement effectivement sur la
séparation entre le banque de dépôt et
banque d'affaires donc les banques dépôt
c'est la banque qu'on connaît tous et la
banque d'affaires c'est celle qu'on que
personne ne connaît dans sa vie
d'investissement
la banque d'investissement que personne
ne connaît dans sa vie ordinaire c'est
celle qui traite avec les entreprises
effectivement c'est vraiment bien
documenté il y a un livre dont je
retrouve pas le titre auquel a contribué
à l'époque Adrien de tricorno qui était
journaliste au Monde il y a aussi plein
d'articles de Laurent Mauduit et même
c'est très connu comme toujours
effectivement que notre cher François
Hollande a été président de la
République c'est lui qui a activement
torpillé le petit début de régulation
qui effectivement était prévu à lieu au
niveau de l'Union européenne soit 10 ans
portée par la France à sur discours à
Paris on y va on va aller à Bruxelles
pour faire l'Europe sociale l'Europe
politique l'Europe du chocolat noir aux
noisettes etc et puis quand on est à
Bruxelles effectivement là on a puisque
encore une fois je reviens à ce que dire
on ne connaît tellement pas notre
économie que les Français ne savent pas
que effectivement nos banques françaises
sont parmi les plus grosses du monde
parmi les plus grosses du monde elles
sont beaucoup beaucoup plus grosses
qu'elles ne devrait être entre
guillemets du fait de la taille de notre
pays la BNP la Société générale ce sont
des acteurs
je suis obligé de vous préciser que
c'est des acteurs c'est vraiment c'est
des acteurs mondiaux face à des monstres
mondiaux depuis des décennies déjà alors
je change complètement de registre parce
que je vais pouvoir faire le lien avec
la vie quotidienne c'est vrai qu'il y a
un truc qui me qui me fatigue de plus en
plus que j'entends dans ma famille ou
partout c'est donc moi je viens d'un
milieu privilégié je suis fils de cadre
etc et je voudrais quand même rappeler
donc à tout à mes cousins mes cousines
certains oncles et tentes etc qui vivent
très très bien que ils ont le droit à un
moment aussi de se bouger et qu'au lieu
de pleurer sur le devenir de leurs
enfants parce qu'il voit bien il voit
bien que c'est plus que compliqué pour
leurs enfants que même quand on fait des
des études en France aujourd'hui ça
devient déjà compliqué de faire des
études il voit bien l'état de nos
universités il voit bien que leurs
enfants arrivent pas à se loger ils
voient bien et pas du tout du tout que
en Île-de-France il voit bien que même
s'il décroche un boulot ils pourront pas
vivre normalement c'est devenu normal
maintenant dans les familles françaises
même quand on est dans mon milieu
bourgeois d'enfants diplômés de ne pas
pouvoir avoir un logement assez grand si
jamais on souhaite produire d'autres
êtres humains on a plus la place pour le
faire enfin on en arrive à des choix qui
sont absurdes pour des gens qui sont
diplômés dans un pays riche et ce qui ne
va pas quand même c'est que donc les
parents ou les grands-parents de ces
jeunes gens ils vont bien et parce qu'on
est en France en fait ils ont beaucoup
de temps libre ils ont beaucoup de temps
et donc il y a toute une génération ou
peut-être deux générations il y a
peut-être un moment il va falloir se
poser la question de est-ce qu'on passe
longtemps à préparer son prochain
week-end au ski son prochain week-end de
plongée ces prochaines vacances à
l'étranger ou juste est-ce qu'un moment
ces gens-là qui n'ont rien fait qui
n'ont rien fait pour avoir tout ce
qu'ils ont à tous ces gens là qui n'ont
jamais manifester qui ont comme j'en
connais des cadres les 9 semaines de
congés payés par an qui ont malgré tout
la sécu pour la santé qui n'ont rien
fait pour tout ça éventuellement un
petit bulletin tous les 5 ans un petit
peu à gauche etc au maximum est-ce que
ces gens-là ils peuvent pas un moment se
dire je vois que tout ça est en train de
disparaître mais je suis quand même
encore dans une démocratie j'ai plein de
temps libre j'ai de l'argent j'ai des
relations sociales est-ce qu'à un moment
je peux peut-être aller voir mon député
dans sa permanence je peux aller voir
mon maire je peux simplement me
présenter aux élections faire de la
politique c'est-à-dire que c'est quand
même pas possible dans notre pays de se
plaindre autant et d'avoir autant de
gens et le jeudi très clairement autant
de gauche que de droite de dire c'est
quand même beaucoup trop facile
effectivement le cataclysme il arrive
mais encore une fois vous l'avez eu
facile enfin la génération de mes
parents ils l'ont eu quand même plus que
facile dans tous les domaines est-ce
qu'il y a un moment c'est pas juste
filer de l'argent à vos petits-enfants
je peux pas juste vous réveiller vous
êtes en bonne santé à tous les les gens
de 70 ans qui qui font quatre fois le
tour de la planète tous les ans etc
est-ce qu'il y a un moment votre temps
libre vous pouvez pas l'utiliser autre
chose ou alors moi juste assumer le fait
que après vous c'est le désert après
vous c'est le cataclysme mais sortez un
peu de ce truc là je crois qu'il y a un
moment il faut aussi un peu se regarder
en face et que quand on est aussi
privilégié que le son quand même malgré
tout beaucoup de gens dans notre pays
dans un pays aussi privilégié que le
nôtre c'est juste pas possible de rien
faire et de juste dire oh là là comme
c'est triste les jeunes c'est dur pour
eux bah vas-y ben bouge-toi le cul
tu as vu soleil hiver mais non j'ai pas
eu sur les verres alors il faut voir sur
l'hiver parce que tes copains là c'est
ce qui leur attend
j'ai la chance moi enfin pour moi
l'universitaire que je suis le fait que
la Sorbonne me donne son grand amphi
jeudi prochain est une ah non mais c'est
c'est ma vraie consécration oh la frime
et en fait sur le thème de que la
démocratie attendait bon et elle est en
déclin pour une raison
qui m'est apparue évidemment c'est que
la démocratie est un concept qui est né
dans un univers clos qui était les
êtres libres d'Athènes ou de Rome
c'est-à-dire avec une certaine
prospérité et que en fait quand on
regarde les étapes de la démocratie dans
l'Occident judéo-chrétien
chaque fois qu'il y a eu prospérité
économique tu as franchi des crans dans
la démocratie et nous sommes passés par
une sorte de pique il y a alors je vais
pas battre mais je dirais 50 60 40 ans
j'en sais rien mais enfin on va dire au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale
premier
jusqu'au juste au premier choc
aujourd'hui l'espoir de la démocratie
est quand même abîmée exactement parce
que tu dis c'est-à-dire que 67% des gens
en droit de voter ne votent pas bien je
dis bien alors il y a des il y a des cas
différents je dirais d'un point de vue
ordre de grandeur les deux tiers
aujourd'hui des personnes qui seraient
en droit de voter ne votent pas pourquoi
parce que je pense que le terreau
de la prospérité par lequel nous sommes
passés n'est plus présent et il crée des
précarités que je qualifie de réel ou de
ressenti la réelle c'est que ce soit aux
États-Unis que ce soit en Allemagne que
ce soit en Angleterre etc des gens qui
ont vraiment des problématiques de
survie
et dont les chiffres sont pas si on les
trouve dans des organisations mais pas
dans les états on trouve pas de
statistiques dans les états en France
oui mais je pense que c'est même
peut-être plus le plus grave que ça et
puis tu as et ça c'est le phénomène qui
m'inquiète c'est le phénomène de la
précarité ressentie et la précarité
ressentie elle vient du fait que comme
il y a eu une extravagance une démesure
dans l'enrichissement des 35 dernières
années
c'est que effectivement celui qui
pourrait une fois tous les 15 jours
offrir une part de pizza assez gamins
dit mais j'en ai marre de voir
effectivement que le concessionnaire de
voiture de sport à la sortie de mon bled
à augmenter la surface de vente
de façon
ostentatoire donc je crains
qu'effectivement il n'y ait cette
fatigue démocratique
le mot n'est pas de moi je crois qu'il
est d'un écrivain indien sur le fait que
la prospérité fertile sur laquelle on
avait construit la démocratie en
Occident ce soit d'éliter ce soit
effrité
ce qu'on vient de ce qu'on vient de dire
à l'instant pour deux raisons la
première c'est à la fois j'entends j'ai
ce que tu dis sur les papy boomers etc
et c'est aussi évidemment le procès qui
est fait par la jeune génération à notre
génération à la génération du dessus
d'un autre côté je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention au fait que la
division entre les Français c'est
exactement ce que notamment ce
gouvernement cette majorité pratique
depuis 5 ans
donc on a vu encore avec la discussion
sur le la grève chez Total et les
raffineries combien de journalistes ont
agressé Martinez la CGT en disant mais
vous avez déjà des avantages sectoraux
au sectoriel à Total et en plus vous en
voulez davantage mais regardez les
autres voilà donc on divise les français
pour mieux régner en vérité et surtout
faire en sorte qu'il y ait aucune prise
en considération globale de la question
de la justice sociale dans ce pays donc
à la fois tu as raison et d'un autre
côté je pense qu'il faut faire attention
c'est à dire ne
surenchons ne faisons pas d'assurance
chair sur la question de la division
entre nous voilà deuxième oignon ceci
sur la question du lien prospérité
démocratie je pense que à la fois je
suis d'accord et il y a un danger quand
même il y a un risque qui est de
conditionner la démocratie à la
prospérité ce n'est pas ce que tu as dit
non voilà mais pour moi c'est
ce qu'un certain nombre de postes
libéraux croix
démocratie abondance bon qui vont dire
la prospérité la démocratie c'est fini
voilà
plus d'énergie la démocratie c'est fini
et alors ça ça me renvoie à mon avis au
fait que nous sommes aujourd'hui en
Europe aux États-Unis au Japon à la
croisée des chemins par rapport en
termes d'économie politique par rapport
au type de société qu'on veut construire
dans les années qui viennent et ça ça
concerne la jeune génération parce que
c'est elle qui va le faire qu'on revient
finalement à la question tout à fait
initiale que tu avais posée d'une
certaine manière on a tous compris et
les politiques l'ont compris aussi les
seuls qui ne veulent pas n'entendre
parler c'est des banquiers des marchés
financiers pour des raisons que je vais
expliciter mais on a tous compris qu'il
faut des carboner mais il y a deux
manières de décarboner malheureusement
il y en a une qui est celle à laquelle
pense tous les militants écolos qui est
une société disons où on décentralise le
pouvoir de production énergétique avec
chacun à son éolienne dans son jardin
c'est pas nos photosvoltaïques sur les
toits etc ce que l'Allemagne avait
commencé de faire dans les années 2010
avec une floraison de coopérative de
production décentralisée d'énergie
qui dit des centralisations la
production en énergie dit commun les
communs dans notre société et dit aussi
démocratie participative c'est ce à quoi
beaucoup des colo pense ils ont bien
raison et là il y a une deuxième option
qui est parfaitement compatible avec la
décarbonation de notre économique qui
est au contraire un état très centralisé
très autoritaire complètement
antidémocratique en alliant avec un
capital privé qui se fiche pas mal de la
question de la démocratie et la justice
sociale pourquoi parce que les
infrastructures liées aux énergies
renouvelables sont beaucoup plus
capitalistiques que les infrastructures
liées aux énergies fossiles donc on a
ces deux grandes options la deuxième
aujourd'hui est incarnée par la Chine
qui continue alors j'espère qu'avec la
guerre en Ukraine c'est terminé mais qui
continue de fasciner une partie de nos
élites européennes combien de fois j'ai
entendu des hauts fonctionnaires
français dire mais quand même finalement
la dictature à la chinoise ça a du bon
parce que on évacue le risque
parlementaire le risque parlementaire
c'est ça veut juste dire la démocratie
justement
c'est juste nous voilà c'est juste nous
voilà alors d'une certaine manière on
pourrait se demander si une hypothèse
que je soumets à la délibération ce que
ce que ce gouvernement et cette majorité
actuelle sont en train de faire c'est
d'essayer de nous pousser doucement vers
la deuxième option avec des effets de
cliquets de manière que petit à petit ne
soit plus possible de revenir en arrière
et d'aller vers la première voilà
la lenteur de la transition énergétique
et écologique plus globalement dans nos
élites occidentales est lié au fait
qu'une partie de nos élites se dit mais
peut-être que la deuxième option est
faisable pour nous et donc on veut
certainement comment dire cadenasser le
débat faire en sorte qu'il n'est pas
lieu promouvoir quelqu'un comme Eric
Zemmour en France qui va complètement
pourrir le débat public en France
pendant cette campagne de manière que
les vrais sujets ne soient jamais
traités c'est quand même impressionnant
que pendant cette campagne on n'est
jamais parlé des vrais questions qui
sont le financement de la retraite sur
lesquels on va avoir un buzz pas
possible au moment où le gouvernement va
nous passer un 49-3 de nouveau l'année
prochaine sur la question du financement
des retraites la question de la sécurité
sociale sur lesquelles il y a pas de
trous en fait donc ça c'est encore un
mythe qu'un gouvernement est en train
d'inventer pour nous raconter qui est le
casser la sécurité sociale la
destruction d'État social en France bon
toutes ces grandes questions sur
lesquelles il faudrait quand même qu'on
puisse avoir des vrais débats
l'énergie nucléaire l'énergie voilà tout
ça rien de tout ça n'a été évoqué
la sécurité alimentaire on a des gens
qui ont faim aujourd'hui en France j'ai
des amis qui ceux qui se prive de repas
pour donner à manger à leurs enfants
voilà
j'avais fait moi 12 propositions on
était dernier en 2021 mis sur la table
pour alimenter le débat et essayer de
faire remonter un tout petit peu le
débat par rapport à la haine habituelle
diffusée par un certain nombre médias et
en premier chef par Éric Zemmour bon
personne ne s'est ressaisi de ces de ses
propositions à part Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a fait un commentaire en disant je
suis en très grande partie d'accord donc
là je peux je peux te couper il faut
quand même prendre la défense derrière
je me fais l'avocat
qu'est-ce que représente Éric Zemmour
alors de mon point de vue avec Zemmour
il y a un très beau libel au seuil qui
est sorti là dessus sur la langue d'Éric
Zemmour
Eric Zemmour il installe dans le
vocabulaire comment bienveillance
il installe dans le vocabulaire dans la
dans la rhétorique dans le lexique que
nous utilisons tous la retribalisation
de l'espace démocratique il réinstalle
ce que kalschmitt avait théorisé dans
les années 30 le juriste allemand en
fait qui a fricoté avec le régime nazi
réinstalle une partition de l'espace
public entre les ennemis eux et nous et
à chaque fois bon l'ennemi change c'est
l'étranger le migrant le réfugier la
femme le Juif le Gitan la femme qui
souffrent dans des cas les homosexuels
etc voilà et nous les autres une espèce
il ne fait que ça c'est exactement ce
que montre ce libel qui est très bien
fait et au fond le reste n'a aucune
importance
pas davantage qu'Emmanuel Macron
intéresse n'a aucune importance qui
compte c'est pour lui et c'est pour ça
que les médias lui ont donné une tribune
c'est cette réorientation cette
restructuration des débat public autour
de la dialectique ennemie amie e on a
droit d'utiliser la violence sur eux les
femmes on peut les battre c'est pas
grave il pense que ce sera bien écrit ça
et nous voilà c'est ça qui est en train
de faire alors aujourd'hui par exemple
on a l'extrême droite qui arrive en
Suède la Suède n'a aucune tradition
fasciste donc ça c'est pas une
résurgence du fascisme non non pas du
tout ça c'est la tribu qui est en train
de
ça
depuis 1945 absolument pas voilà
donc c'est la tribu entre guillemets
avec 40 guillemets la tribu blanche qui
a peur de quoi a-t-elle peur
fondamentalement elle a peur
fondamentalement des cataclysmes qui
sont en train d'arriver qui sont induits
essentiellement par la réfraction des
ressources naturelles énergies minerais
par le dérèglement climatique et par les
crises sociales dont on a déjà parlé
mais au lieu d'adresser c'est vrai
question et d'organiser un vrai débat
démocratique ça c'est question là la
tribu blanc ce Christ et dans un réflexe
sectaire identitaire se dit on va
trouver des boucs émissaires sur
lesquels on va taper ça va faire du bien
et la Commission européenne
malheureusement est complice de ça Renzi
en Italie qu'à priori on identifie on
identifierait pas tellement à une ligne
zémurienne Renzi a négocié en fait j'ai
appris ça il y a pas très longtemps qui
je peux pas le dire Renzi a négocié
lorsqu'il était Premier Ministre enfin
président du Conseil italien
le fait que il est des largesses en
termes de manœuvre budgétaire accordée
par la Commission européenne contre le
fait qu'il abandonne les politiques de
soutien aux MIG qui traverse la
Méditerranée donc l'Italie a
délibérément laissé mourir les migrants
dans la Méditerranée en échange de quoi
la Commission européenne a fermé les
yeux c'est très très grave
ça va être ça va être rendu public dans
les mois qui viennent tout à fait et
donc ça ça veut dire que on a d'un côté
cette tribalisation du discours public
qui est extrêmement dangereux qu'on
retrouve aux États-Unis avec Trump et
malheureusement Trump n'est pas mort
politiquement vous avez vu que
maintenant il est cité à comparaître au
congrès à cause de ce qui s'est passé le
6 janvier il peut être accusé et
peut-être condamné de complicité pour
tentative de coup d'État et donc de
haute trahisons par rapport à l'état
américain
mais la situation est extrêmement
compliquée pour les Américains parce que
il est Excel dans l'art de se faire
passer pour un martyre donc la question
c'est comment est-ce que les trumpistes
vont réagir à ce point mais disons le
mouvement de trumpiste aidé par les
réseaux sociaux est essentiellement un
mouvement sectaire de réflexe d'une
partie de la classe moyenne américaine
avec 40 équipes et blanches avec 40
guillemets qui a peur et qui se dit bon
les responsables ce sont les hispaniers
sont les Mexicains ce sont les
Asiatiques ce sont les Blacks etc ça n'a
rien à voir avec le sujet une fois de
plus on cherche des boucs émissaires
pour se voiler la face par rapport à la
vraie question qui aujourd'hui comment
est-ce que on fait face à la réflexion
des ressources énergétiques
et au dérèglement climatique
moi j'ai une lecture qui est un tout
petit peu différente au sens où
par exemple sur reprendre le cas des
États-Unis encore une fois je sais pas
du tout pour
pour chercher des coupables mais il y a
vraiment il y a factuellement une
responsabilité majeure d'une certaine
gauche et que tant que cette gauche là
n'aura pas reconnu ça je crains vraiment
pour dire simplement je crains vraiment
pour l'avenir de la démocratie en France
et ailleurs pour être très concret aux
États-Unis
qui a été le plus grand héros de la
mondialisation qui assis parce que les
États-Unis sont un pays fermés
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
protectionniste
et les États-Unis quand vous êtes un
très grand pays c'est assez simple à
comprendre vous êtes en plus un pays
très développé la plupart des ressources
vous avez chez vous on oublie toujours
on la prend à savoir on la prend au
lycée puis on l'oublie les États-Unis
les productions naturelles aux
États-Unis sont énormes premier
producteur de blé le premier producteur
de pétrole au sens large aujourd'hui
c'est les États-Unis quand vous
Etats-Unis vous avez tout ah vous avez
la haute technologie vous avez les
ressources naturelles vous avez tout et
donc vous échangez en fait beaucoup
moins avec l'étranger relativement à la
part de votre économie nationale que un
pays comme la France qui importe et qui
exporte beaucoup plus en proportion de
de du gâteau national aux États-Unis les
personnes qui ont été les plus
enthousiastes auprès de la
mondialisation les personnes qui ont
signé le plus grand accord commercial
des États-Unis de libre-échange entre
les États-Unis le Canada et le Mexique
c'est Bill Clinton c'est la gauche c'est
la gauche progressiste
de même qu'aux États-Unis au Royaume-Uni
la personne qui a été la plus
enthousiaste en faveur de la
mondialisation ça a été Tony Blair de
même qu'en France les personnes qui ont
fait cette atroce sur mondialisation
c'est hyper mondialisation qui est
l'union européenne c'est Jacques Delors
et François Mitterrand et ces gens-là si
vous voulez ont additionner un discours
enthousiaste moralisateur bénéfique de
la mondialisation alors que là pour le
coup pour reprendre si on était un tout
petit peu honnête sur le plan économique
il y avait aucune chance que ça
bénéficiait la classe moyenne parce que
même dans les pires manuels de notre
discipline il est clairement dit là
c'est vous pouvez aller dans n'importe
quelle librairie vous reprenez les
manuels de première année sur le
commerce international même les
professeurs des universités américaines
vous disent le libre-échange fait des
perdants le libre-échange fait des
perdants on sait très bien qui c'est des
gens qui sont dans les hauts de France
aujourd'hui et en fait comment est-ce
qu'il sauve leur modèle dans ses cours
là qu'est-ce que tu ne raconter Pascal
Lamy pendant des années c'est qu'ils
inventent une gentille institution
redistributrice qui va parce
qu'effectivement il y a des gars au
commerce international qui va gentiment
compenser les perdants moi cette
compensation des perdants évidemment
elle a jamais eu lieu nulle part donc là
il y a le responsabilité et si on
reprend donc vraiment de la gauche et si
on prend le cas de la Suède
malheureusement c'est un domaine que je
connais assez bien sur lequel j'enseigne
le modèle social suédois était très
particulier au sens où effectivement ils
avaient des impôts plus élevés que nous
mais qui bénéficient à l'ensemble de la
population il faut voir que les
inégalités de revenus pendant très
longtemps qui est très très faible en
Suède pour dire les choses simplement
quand vous étiez cadre même cadre
supérieur en Suède vous ne pouviez pas
embaucher une femme de ménage ça n'était
trop cher pour vous parce que les écarts
de salaire étaient étaient trop faibles
vous payez énormément d'impôts mais en
contrepartie vous aviez non seulement
comme chez nous la santé la retraite
mais aussi par exemple un système
d'éducation et de recherche extrêmement
performant dont vous bénéficiez vous vos
enfants et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la Suède au cours des crises
successives et évidemment pas leur
reprocher
à droite oui à accueilli une part de
migrants beaucoup plus importante par
rapport à sa population que n'importe
quel autre pays peut-être quasiment dans
le monde en tout cas en Europe c'est sûr
déjà avec la guerre en Bosnie des années
90 puis toutes les crises la Syrie la
Libye évidemment l'Ukraine etc à chaque
fois qu'il y a des crises les Suédois
ont accueilli énormément de migrants et
là pour différentes raisons et qu'il y a
mon avis sont en partie biologique
c'est-à-dire de l'oubli aussi
effectivement de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale les nouvelles générations qui
arrivent il y a un discours qui a
commencé à monter les médias ont joué
leur rôle les parties droites ont joué
leur eau on a commencé à souffler sur
les braises du racisme et ça
effectivement très bien marché il y a
l'idée de dire moi je voulais bien payer
beaucoup d'impôts en fait quand c'était
pour moi ou quand c'était comme pour des
gens comme moi entre guillemets mais je
veux pas payer pour les autres
d'ailleurs c'est une des explications
qui est donnée sur l'absence d'état
social aux États-Unis c'est la division
raciale aux États-Unis parce qu'il y
avait l'idée chez tout un tas
d'électeurs blancs de dire je ne veux
pas payer beaucoup d'impôts pour la
protection sociale parce que ils croyait
que la protection sociale allait avant
tout bénéficier au noir et donc c'est
pour ça que je pense que la question
sociale est absolument et absolument
fondamentale et que là aussi les
décennies qui qui sont passées de
travail idéologique au quand même très
bien marché et donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit Gaël Giraud
tout à l'heure que effectivement on a ce
gros problème mais je pense qu'il faut
l'affronter de face que je suis content
que gajiro reprenne ma crise ma grille
de lecture marxiste sur que l'opposition
fondamentale c'est entre le capital et
le travail tout à fait d'accord il faut
surtout pas diviser les travailleurs
mais je pense la question
générationnelle et les majeure dans
toutes les conférences où elle est les
jeunes ont la haine des vieux et je peux
le comprendre et quand on regarde les
réformes actuelles par exemple sur
l'assurance chômage qui sont dingue
c'est que ça fait deux fois ça fait deux
fois que le gouvernement actuel et le
précédent réduisent les allocations
chômage on se rappelle la fameuse
conférence de presse de Muriel Pénicaud
à l'Elysée avec Édouard Philippe à
l'époque disant cette réforme va
accroître la précarité cette réforme va
accroître la précarité ce qu'elle a fait
bref et bien quand on regarde dans les
sondages surtout quand on compare
l'évolution des sondages au cours du
temps ces réformes sont soutenues par
une majorité de la population et
malheureusement quand on pose la
question aux gens est-ce que les
chômeurs sont trop assistés etc on a
maintenant une nette majorité alors
c'est vraiment
des sondages qui veulent pas dire
grand-chose dans l'absolu mais un des
derniers sondages qui est sorti ces
dernières semaines nous montre que dans
toutes les catégories sociales les
cadres les vieux évidemment qu'ils sont
les pires les ouvriers etc vous avez un
soutien une majorité très net pour dire
que effectivement la protection sociale
doit être diminuée et là ça
l'enseignement qu'on connaît nous très
bien de l'histoire c'est que quand vous
réduisez les droits sociaux comme c'est
le cas depuis des années quand vous
dites comme tous les gouvernements nous
ont dit que les problèmes c'est notre
faute à nous les salariés lorsque la
pauvreté progresse et bien les gens sont
de moins en moins solidaires et je
voudrais juste donner juste dernière
petite référence que vous disiez sur les
États-Unis on sait que l'espérance de
vie diminue aux Etats-Unis et donc à nos
chers prix Nobel Angus 10 tonnes je vous
conseille ce livre traduit en français
qui s'appelle Mor de désespoir au
pluriel Angus 10 tonnes mort de
désespoir qui explique effectivement on
a toute une classe ouvrière américaine
qui vit tellement mal que les gens se
droguent c'est connu et que l'espérance
de vie a chuté et tout dernier fait il y
a une étude qui en fait tout un tas
d'études précédentes qui montrent que
dans la qualité de vie psychologique des
gens s'effondre à un seuil qui a 1500
euros par mois et donc il y avait déjà
d'autres études il y a plein de trucs
très bien fait on demande aux gens pour
vous combien ce qu'il faut pour vivre et
en fait la moyenne c'est 1500 petits
problèmes si vous prenez ce seuil de
1500 pour survivre non pour vivre pour
vivre enfin voilà pour pour vivre bon en
tout cas c'est pour vivre mais si on
prenait ce seuil simplement de 1500
euros par mois pour une personne seule
c'est 30% de la population et donc
effectivement moi je considère qu'on
peut dire aujourd'hui qu'en France en
gros une personne sur trois est pauvre
et en plus c'est validé parce que c'est
un travail d'une jeune chercheuse
excellente de l'École d'économie de
Paris qui qui renvoie à d'autres à
d'autres travaux précédents voilà et
donc et donc je pense effectivement que
à la fois on est un pays très très riche
et ça n'est pas du tout paradoxal avec
le fait qu'il y a une pauvreté massive à
obéir un tire bon et ensuite je vous
envoie sur le prix Nobel d'économie
d'accord sur la Suède la on a aussi fait
des bêtises par exemple en 2003 elle est
passée à la retraite par point qui est
aussi un des objectifs de gouvernement
et la conséquence de ceci c'est que les
allocations retraite ont effectivement
diminué donc ça a permis de faire des
économies mais on a créé un personnage
qui n'existait pas en Suède qui est le
vieux pauvre et donc on a 15 % des
seigneurs suédois depuis 2003 qui sont
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté donc ça
aussi ça joue dans l'acceptation tout
d'un coup du fait que on a des thèses
racistes qui rémergent en Suède
évidemment si vous êtes un senior et que
et que vous n'avez plus n'arrivez plus à
vivre vous pouvez être tenté
malheureusement de commencer à céder aux
sirènes du tribalisme à la suédoise
voilà ça ça me semble important l'autre
chose tout à fait d'accord
malheureusement sur la question des
allocations chômage il y a un mythe qui
est celui du chômeur assisté il faut
rappeler que il y a 40% des chômeurs
uniquement qui touchent leur cotisations
chômage il y a 60% des chômeurs qui ne
touchent pas qui ne perçoivent pas leurs
élèves soit qu'il a réclame pas soit
qu'il n'y arrive pas ok voilà alors en
plus de ça les chiffres du chômage sont
essentiellement trompeurs en réalité
aujourd'hui en équivalent temps plein on
a 30% de chômage en France je crois
qu'il faut le redire à tout le monde
c'est très simple à comprendre imaginez
que vous avez deux économies une
économie a une économie B et Gilles et
moi nous sommes tous les deux les deux
partenaires de cette économie dans
l'économie a j'ai le travail à 100% moi
à 0 dans l'économie B on travaille tous
les deux à 50 avec les statistiques
officielles l'économie B est en pleine
emploi
l'économie a 50% de chômage en réalité
si on réfléchit deux minutes on voit
bien que ces deux économies sont
équivalentes donc si on reformule le
chômage en équivalent en plein on est à
30% de chômeurs en France 25% en
Allemagne entre 20 et 25 30% aux
États-Unis donc c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui donc le fantasme du chômeur
insisté ça c'est encore une construction
idéologique pour culpabiliser un certain
nombre de gens diviser les salariés
entre eux et dire regardez en fait on va
on va arrêter de
on va réduire les allocations chômage au
passage sur la sur cette proposition de
l'actuel gouvernement qui est de réduire
le temps des allocations chômage pour
inciter à aller chercher un autre boulot
ça a été fait en Allemagne en 2002 avec
les accords arts 2002 2003 et c'était
garde ce qui va tout à fait dans ton
sens un malheureusement c'est la social
démocratie qui met en œuvre ce type de
réforme catastrophique quel a été la
conséquence la conséquence a été une
déflation salariale extrêmement grave en
Allemagne et là aussi l'apparition d'un
nouveau personnage social en Allemagne
qui le travailleur pauvre qui n'existait
pas en allemand qui a fait surface en
Allemagne qui n'existait plus depuis
1945 grâce à garde voilà sur la question
de la compromission de la de la gauche
de la sociale démocratie en tout cas
avec toutes ces réformes il y a un livre
absolument remarquable de raoui Abdellah
profard qui s'appelle les règles du
capital capital Moon en anglais et qui
décrit tout ça donc il y a eu une espèce
de de coalition en fait d'une certaine
sociale démocratie qui en réalité était
à mon avis un peu perdu point de vue
doctrinal avec parce qu'elle a mis à
l'OMC Jacques Delors à l'Europe y
compris comme Dominique Strauss-Kahn au
FMI voilà et donc tous ces grandes
institutions internationales ont
collaboré pour construire la
globalisation marchande c'est qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui et peut-être qu'elle
nous fait souffrir le paradoxe c'est que
ce soit la sociale démocratique et les
faits pourquoi à mon avis parce que il y
a une espèce de fascination dans les
années 80 pour les marchés financiers à
gauche parce que les marchés financiers
représentaient d'un point de vue
complètement imaginaire une espèce
d'alternative à la lutte des classes
pourquoi parce que dans les banques sur
les marchés financiers il n'y a pas de
colle bleue il y a pas d'ouvriers c'est
pas ça il y a pas de grandes cheminées
fumantes qui polluent et donc d'une
certaine manière ça donnait l'illusion
d'un monde socialement apaisé dans
lequel tout le monde pourrait collaborer
l'école bleue à l'école blanc parce
qu'il y avait plus de colle bleue voilà
et donc je crois que c'est pour ça la
fascination d'une partie de la gauche
pour les marchés financiers
outre les questions de corruption
individuelle bon qui j'espère restent
relativement marginal c'est quand même
ça donc c'est une erreur du diagnostic
absolument majeur je juste un mot
là-dessus
c'est que
il y avait dans à cette même période où
j'ai commencé moi à travailler
il y avait cette espèce de délit
internationale qui décrié le
paternalisme industriel et qui est en
fait penser qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes
concepteur et contributeurs d'une cité
idéale dans laquelle justement il n'y
avait plus de lutte de classe puisque
par le progrès
qui passait par la technologie qui
passait par toute une série de de
disposition on allait accéder à une
sorte d'euphorie
dans laquelle justement il n'y avait
plus de lutte de classe et ce que tu
décris moi je les dénoncé à plusieurs
reprises c'est que c'est en fait la
sociale démocratie
slash progressiste et qui
sait de mon point de vue affranchi de
l'origine du progrès le progrès de
Victor Hugo c'est à dire
fondamentalement la défense de la veuve
et de l'orphelin
a été
escamoté dans la mesure où ils ont été
séduits par une forme progressiste de
l'idéal
et pratiquement en disant non non mais
la veuve et l'orphelin elle va trouver
sa solution dans cette sortie par le
haut
etc
question sur le prix Nobel d'économie de
[Rires]
reçoit le prix Nobel d'économie est-ce
que c'est pas ça il y en a deux autres
est-ce que c'est pas la consécration du
boomer la consécration de la politique
économique pour et par le boomer c'était
vas-y alors pour moi si tu veux je suis
le témoin dans ma propre dans mon propre
entre soi dont je rappelle j'ai été le
plus élevé des plus pauvres et qui m'a
toujours permis de voir ce qui se
passait au-dessus c'est-à-dire que
j'avais plus élevés c'est ça
c'est que nous avons contribué à une
imposture
l'imposture d'une d'une
croissance qui s'est substituée à la
prospérité le monde croissance
n'existait pas avant je dis dans la
période de
toujours de 1815 à 1915
je n'ai pas vu ce genre de dire il va y
avoir de la croissance
le monde de croissance n'existait pas et
donc
tout ce que je défends en ce moment
c'est que en fait le mot de croissance
qui s'est substitué à la prospérité
et devenu la boussole au moment où elle
a commencé à décliner
à 10 ans près c'est à dire qu'à partir
de 1970 les l'ensemble des statistiques
de la C2 de la Banque mondiale montrent
un déclin de la croissance
mais non seulement il y a ce déclin mais
que en plus on est rentré dans une phase
qui a été pour moi une révélation d'une
note de la fête de 2002 où on s'aperçoit
que effectivement des pays comme les
États-Unis sont rentrés sauf les années
Clinton dans une période de croissance à
crédit permanent et donc quand on fait
la simple soustraction sur laquelle tu
avais eu la gentillesse de m'inviter la
première fois c'est que en de façon
arithmétique ça veut dire que depuis 40
ans s'il n'y avait pas eu le crédit nous
aurions été au mieux en stagnation au
pied en récession
première imposture et la deuxième c'est
que j'ai déjà évoqué ce nom ce nom de la
valeur
en réalité
absence de vrais croissance que je
qualifierai de naturel de bio OK et
absent de vraies créations de richesse
fait que effectivement comme l'avait dit
un ami juif qui a été mon comptable et
au moment où je lui ai demandé un coup
de main en fin d'année il me dit oui
mais ma femme et ma sœur sont comptables
etc mais il me dit mais je veux pas
parce que un juif sur le groupe ça passe
2 je vais créer un phénomène de rejet
c'était il y a 35 ans c'est horrible
c'est horrible mais Marc qui me regarde
peut-être qui qui est en retraite en
Israël en fait savait qu'il y avait une
forme de rejet à partir d'un certain
seuil et le problème de mon point de vue
c'est que la montée que je
on dénonce tous enfin je veux dire c'est
monstrueux c'est effectivement à partir
du moment où le gâteau
au mieux et rester le vrai et rester à
peu près constant celui qui rentre
aujourd'hui il va mécaniquement me
prendre une partie et au lieu donc là
c'est la dimension chrétienne que je
veux dans ma vie chrétien qui est à
gauche absolument non mais je revendique
d'être un chrétien et de dire à ce
moment-là il faut organiser la vie pour
que l'autre soit accueilli mais ça je
peux te dire que dans mon univers je
suis à ce moment-là traité de bolchevik
etc toute façon c'est tout simple
non non mon père mon père m'a permis de
dire je suis creusois du côté de ma mère
mais
mais mais mais
du côté de ma mère et catalan de l'autre
donc quand on est catalan je veux dire
la notion d'anarchie et proche donc je
dirais que je suis un anarchiste
conservateurs
donc c'est un prix Nobel extrêmement
paradoxal parce que Ben Bernard a été
donc le patron de la Fed pendant les
années qui ont précédé la grande crise
des subprimes de 2007 il succédé à Dan
Greenspan et ben non tu es l'homme qui
n'a pas vu venir la crise de 2007-2008
qui n'a rien compris à la stabilisation
d'inflation aux États-Unis entre 2001 et
2007 qui a chanté en fait les louanges
de cette pseudo-stabilisation en disant
nous avons vaincu le phénomène de
l'inflation aux États-Unis alors qu'il
ne voyait pas du tout ce que tu viens
d'écrire à l'instant c'est-à-dire
l'explosion de la dette privée aux
États-Unis pas la dette publique la
dette privée voilà et le fait que la
totalité des économie grande partie
d'économie américaine j'ai commencé à
vivre complètement à crédit et n’était
pas en mesure de rembourser cette dette
on va y revenir d'ailleurs jusqu'à un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui au niveau mondial
sur le remboursement de la dette voilà
donc que est celui qui n'a rien vu de
tout ça aujourd'hui il est il est il est
récompensé avec le prix Nobel les deux
autres d'ailleurs sont deux
universitaires tout à fait remarquables
qui ont produit un modèle qu'on appelle
le modèle de Diamond dipling qui est un
modèle du secteur bancaire alors ça va
peut-être surprendre ceux qui nous
écoutent mais le prix de la Banque de
Suède d'ailleurs oui c'est vrai oui
parce que vous savez qu'elle phénomène
n'avait pas autorisé qu'on attribue le
prix Nobel à cause de sa femme
à cause de sa femme bon en tout cas ça
c'est vrai pour les mathématiques parce
que sa femme est trompée avec un
mathématicien
le
donc Diama didvig on fait un modèle
bancaire dans lequel il n'y a pas de
monnaie il y a pas de banque
alors j'explique un tout petit peu dans
ce modèle les banques ce qu'il appelle
des banques sont les institutions
financières qui empruntent de la main
droite ce qu'elle reprenne la main
gauche ça c'est pas une banque ça c'est
un fond par exemple un fond de gestion
qui ne crée pas de monnaie une banque
c'est une institution financière qui
crée la monnaie ex nihilo il faut le
redire à tout le monde et lorsque je
vais voir de rien à partir de rien dans
ce que je vais voir mon banquier que je
lui demande un crédit pour acheter un
appartement ou que sais-je l'essentiel
de l'argent que me donne ce que me
crédites se banquier n'a été produit par
rien ça veut dire c'est une ligne sur un
écran d'ordinateur
c'est le métier de la banquier c'est
normal c'est pas de la magie c'est pour
ça qu'il faut attribuer une licence
bancaire pour que tout le monde ne peut
pas s'improviser banquier puisque c'est
quand même un pouvoir phénoménal que de
créer de la monnaie alors au passage
ceux qui croient que la création
monétaire est toujours inflationniste
devrait militer pour la fermeture de
toutes les banques puisque les banques
créent de la monnaie en permanence donc
évidemment que la création monétaire
n'est pas ipsofacto-inflationniste
contrairement à ce que nous chantons les
postes libéraux qui vont pouvoir
aujourd'hui alors donc premièrement les
banques créent de la monnaie dans le
modèle de Monique elle n'en crée pas
donc c'est un peu compliqué pour dire
que ce sont des banques ensuite la
monnaie la quantité de monnaie en
circulation a un impact énorme sur le
l'essentiel de la macroéconomie
sur les marchés financiers où elles font
des bulles colossales qui de temps en
temps explose mais également sur la
dette sur le chômage sur la croissance
sur le déficit la balance commerciale
etc dans ces modèles là quand on nous
parle de monnaie c'est une monnaie qui
n'a aucun impact sur l'économie réelle
donc elle est prétendument neutre c'est
le vocabulaire technique qu'on utilise
autrement dit ces économistes là croient
que si je multiplie par deux la quantité
de monnaie en circulation ça n'aura
aucun impact sur l'économie réelle sinon
la multiplication par 2 de tous les prix
et les salaires tout le reste étant
échangé ce qui n'est évidemment pas vrai
alors ça c'est invalidé par des dizaines
de papiers empiriques académiques qui
ont montré que c'est pas vrai et donc on
donne aujourd'hui le prix Nobel à disons
probablement l'un des plus mauvais
président de banque centrale de notre
histoire récente des 4 dernières années
avec Alan Griezmann et par ailleurs à
deux économistes qui ont fait un modèle
et puis par la deux économistes qui ont
fait un modèle d'un système bancaire
dans lequel il y a pas de monnaie il y a
pas de banque voilà donc ça dit quelque
chose aussi la difficulté pour la
communauté scientifique des économistes
aujourd'hui à appréhender la réalité
qu'elle a notre Gilles oui alors c'est
tellement alors je pense vraiment que
enfin moi c'est des choses que je trouve
très c'est très problématique de dire ça
mais c'est la réalité ce que vient
d'expliquer Gaëlle Giraud est tellement
vrai que en fait si par hasard vous avez
vraiment rien d'autre à faire dans votre
vie et que vous allez sur le site
des prix Nobel et sur le site du prix
Nobel d'économie il y a un petit schéma
effectivement il y a un petit schéma
presque enfantin qui explique exactement
ce que vous venez d'expliquer sur ces
banques qui comme on le croit tous
puisque encore une fois ça n'a pas été
appris à l'école on ne nous explique pas
en France comment fonctionne une banque
c'est ces prodigieux personne ne sait
comment fonctionne une banque et
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
qui est étonnant c'est toujours un truc
qui étonne le plus les étudiants quand
on leur dit ce qui est une réalité et
qui n'a rien à voir avec les moyens
électroniques modernes les banques de la
définition d'une banque a toujours été
de créer de l'argent à partir de rien
hein fameuse phrase en économie les
crédits font les défauts
l'absus les les peaux et donc le petit
schéma qui a été fait parce que c'est
très bien fait sur le site du prix Nobel
évidemment malheureusement c'est en
anglais seulement
ou qui explique de façon un peu simple
pourquoi on a donné le prix Nobel donc
de la Banque de Suède à ces gens-là et
bien ce dessin il faut ce dessin est
faux et vous trouverez plein de
d'économistes qui l'ont dit
d'universitaires et donc nous les
économistes en tant que profession on
essaye quand même d'être des gens
sérieux de produire de la connaissance
l'institution suprême qui nous
représente là cette année effectivement
à valider une théorie Jack et vieille
c'est un vieux papier des années 1980
qui est effectivement qui est le seul
intérêt était mathématiques si on peut
dire s'il y en a qui en avait un et donc
ce modèle est faux donc ça c'est quand
même assez vertigineux et je comprends
que ça puisse alimenter une défiance
totale vis-à-vis des intellectuels et
tout mais nous on est bien obligé de
dire la réalité des choses et donc voilà
ce modèle est vraiment faux je voulais
faire un petit un aussi rebond sur ce
que vous avez dit ce qui me paraît
vraiment très très important que
effectivement lorsque le gâteau
économique cesse de croître il y a cette
idée que parce que c'est je pense que
c'est un fil conducteur très important
ce soir que le voisin devient mon ennemi
que effectivement je cherche à me garer
dans Paris on est deux pour une place de
parking c'est vous ou c'est moi mais
c'est pas tous les deux et il se trouve
que là je suis en train en fin de lire
le rapport beverage dont le titre
absolument magnifique qui s'appelle
plein d'emploi dans une société libre et
donc beuverie est un libéral il a dirigé
la lodenschool économics le fameux
institution pendant de nombreuses années
et se définit très clairement comme
libéral de même que Kate et ben vous dit
exactement ça il nous dit la
responsabilité de l'État donc c'est un
livre de 1944 c'est le deuxième rapport
d'everges il nous dit la responsabilité
de l'État c'est de faire en sorte que
justement
que vous n'ayez plus peur que vous
n'ayez plus peur que vous n'ayez plus
peur de l'avenir que vous n'avez plus
peur de votre voisin évidemment si on
fait un saut dans le temps la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est d'activement
créer cette peur il souhaite que nous
ayons peur de l'avenir c'est pour ça
qu'il nous blesse nos retraites il
souhaite que nous ayons peur du chômage
c'est pour ça qu'ils baisent la location
chômage puisque la peur évidemment il y
a un moyen très simple de contrôler les
populations par contre effectivement on
sait que c'est le terreau du racisme et
là je pense que ce point de vue là
Emmanuel Macron a un projet politique
avec un P majuscule très très clair qui
est effectivement de faire activement
reculer le bien-être la démocratie
sociale pour avoir de plus en plus de
pouvoir sur nos vies et et sur nos
sociétés et donc je veux quand même
rappeler que cette tradition libérale
bon enfin le texte de Beverly j'ai
absolument magnifique et il réfléchit en
permanence à dire effectivement bon
quelles sont les libertés qui
éventuellement seraient à Moinerie par
une politique de plein emploi et il nous
dit très clairement et vraiment c'est
magnifique ce raisonnement il nous dit
là justement la propriété privée des
moyens de production des entreprises ils
disent ça n'est pas une liberté
fondamentale ça n'est pas vrai il nous
dit encore une fois c'est quelqu'un de
très pragmatique qui avait travaillé
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale déjà
à organiser le fonctionnement de
l'économie britannique et nous dit ça
les il y a des la liberté d'expression
c'est fondamentale liberté syndicale
c'est fondamentale et liberté de la
presse c'est fondamentale mais le fait
de gérer les entreprises de posséder une
entreprise ça n'est pas une liberté
fondamentale et donc quand il écrit
évidemment en 1944 beveridges il a vécu
et c'est ça qui explique ce merveilleux
moment on peut dire de l'histoire de
l'humanité en tout cas dans les pays
riches il a vécu la crise des années 30
qu'est-ce que c'est la crise à 30 c'est
la démonstration que le libre marché
peut s'autodétruire peut détruire
l'économie peut détruire la démocratie
c'est-à-dire que le marché laissez
absolument à lui-même quand il y a pas
d'institution sociale ni d'État pour
l'encadrer en fait à la raison pour
laquelle pourquoi est-ce que le seul
fait économique majeur qu'on enseigne
vraiment à tous nos lycéens c'est la
crise de 1929 parce que la fin de la
crise 29 c'est Auschwitz c'est le
nazisme c'est pour ça que c'est enseigné
et d'autre part d'everidges qu'est-ce
qu'il a vécu il a vécu la victoire des
États-Unis sur l'Allemagne nazie par la
production industrielle à ce moment là
l'économie américaine est entièrement
planifié c'est-à-dire vous avez un
bureau qui affecte les travailleurs les
travailleurs ce qui fixent les prix
capacité c'est une économie de
rationnement c'est en fait l'économie
soviétique et donc ces gens-là qui sont
très intelligents comme lui comme les
planificateurs français en 1945 ils ont
cette double expérience l'échec du
marché et le succès d'une économie
coordonnée planifiée donc ils vont
mettre en place des économies organisées
et sur le plan moral il vous revendiquer
très clairement le fait que c'est la
responsabilité de l'État d'assurer le
plein emploi et c'est pas la
responsabilité des individus et encore
une fois ces gens-là dans la tradition
de Kens justement c'est toutes l'ironie
de la chose le fond justement parce
qu'ils veulent préserver le marché ils
veulent préserver le marché de lui-même
et aussi parce que il y a la menace
entre guillemets communiste le Parti
communiste français et le deuxième
partie du pays jusqu'à la fin des années
70 il y a le prestige de l'Union
soviétique prestige intellectuel en
particulier en France communisme très
fort aussi en Italie l'Union soviétique
sert de modèle etc mais donc je
rappelais que il y a cette tradition
libérale qui existait et que donc c'est
bien pour ça et je suis attaché assez
cher beveridges que je chéris de toute
mon âme et donc c'est pour ça je trouve
que c'est une grosse erreur encore une
fois de de qualifier les libéraux de
qualifier de libéraux des gens comme
Emmanuel Macron et pardon là je suis
très long mais je voulais te dire un
autre truc qui n'a strictement rien à
voir c'est que si on se place
et aussi je voyage commander une pizza
une pizza hawaïenne s'il vous plaît non
c'est que sur la non mais sur la
transition écologique je pense qu'il y a
un truc qui nous rend fou et que moi
j'ai compris qu'à serrer récemment donc
je vous fais part de ma découverte c'est
que si on sort de toutes les grandes
discussions sur l'énergie et tout ça si
on se ramène encore une fois non non
mais si on se ramène juste c'est juste
un manque de vues c'est complémentaire
ce qu'on a dit là c'est vraiment c'est
un angle de vue parmi d'autres
à mon échelle à l'échelle de chacun
d'entre nous si on compare l'économie
actuelle ma vie actuelle et ma vie dans
une vraie sobriété ce qui est sidérant
et là et c'est totalement nouveau c'est
que je gagne sur tous les plans et donc
là je pense que c'est ça aussi qui nous
fait complètement bugger le cerveau
c'est-à-dire que si je mange moins de
viande si je remplace ma bagnole par du
vélo si mon acier mon logement est isolé
etc toutes choses très très simple à
faire je vis mieux je suis en meilleure
santé physique je suis en meilleure
santé mentale donc je coûte moins cher à
la sécu et même mon niveau de vie
matérielle il augmente
non mais alors justement alors très très
je remercie cette question végétarien et
donc c'est ce que font
que du bœuf végétal et donc non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que ce truc là
que font effectivement plein de gens et
il y a plein de gens aujourd'hui qui
modifient complètement leur mode de vie
non mais si tu résonnes à l'échelle de
la France je pense que ce qui nous rend
fou avec nous les économistes et dans la
politique normalement il y a toujours
des choix on perd d'un côté on gagne de
l'autre mais là si tu réfléchis encore
une fois si chacun fait le bilan
tranquillement tu travailles moins tu
pollues beaucoup moins tu arrêtes tous
les déchets etc encore une fois tu vis
mieux sur tous les plans tu es plus
gentil exactement tu tends la main c'est
ça
c'est vraiment génial c'est les
bisounours
Friedman Friedman était pour la
légalisation des drogues donc je vais je
vais le suivre je vais le suivre sur ce
point là non mais ça je pense que enfin
c'est fou c'est à dire qu'avant même
qu'avant par exemple dans les débats
qu'on avait avant entre je sais pas à
droite et gauche entre socialisme et
capitalisme il y avait du plus et du
moins mais notre vie en fait folle cette
course à la vitesse etc il y a beaucoup
de choses que dit François Ruffin en ce
moment avec lesquels je me retrouve
entièrement c'est à dire que cette vie
complètement de taré on voit bien je
passe des heures dans ma bagnole pour
aller faire un boulot de merde pour
acheter de la merde bouffer de la merde
etc je vois bien encore une fois surtout
dans un pays riche comme la France que
je pourrait matériellement
économiquement vivent complètement
différemment dire surgile je suis obligé
de rebondir sur Gilles si tu fais ça
dans une société mondialisée tu vas te
faire éclater par les autres si la
France se met à agir comme tu viens de
le décrire on se fait éclater à côté de
la Chine elle passe au rouleau
compresseur elle va écraser au bulldozer
une bande de hippie alors franchement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors la réponse
est trop longue et mais je franchement
je pense pas au sens où déjà l'économie
française est pas si mondialisée que ça
et où d'autre part tu pourrais enfin on
aurait pu parce que j'y crois plus donc
je vais être sincère j'y crois plus mais
ce qui avait réussi par exemple la Suède
à une certaine époque c'est qu'on
appelle une économie à deux secteurs
c'est-à-dire que tu as un secteur de
l'économie extrêmement compétitif
concurrentiel appuyé sur la recherche de
points de haut niveau qui exporte et par
exemple les Suédois étaient tout à fait
à la pointe à un moment avec Nokia etc
alors font souverain non non là c'est
vraiment industrer non là c'est vraiment
industriel la Suède par exemple faut
quand même le savoir était comme l'état
social le plus développé du monde sans
déficit public sans difficulté de public
sans déficit commercial ils avaient des
excédents partout parce que tu as ce
secteur mais vraiment avec une économie
archi organisée des supers industriels à
super-État ultra efficace que des
hydrocarbures ces gens-là justement la
Suède ils ont rien c'est pour ça que
c'est un exemple intéressant et si tu
gagnes et vraiment ça marche sur le
tableau noir l'économie c'est ça a
marché dans la réalité mais ça s'est
cassé la gueule et je pense que pour la
France c'est un choix qu'on aurait pu
faire une certaine époque mais qu'on n'a
pas fait et je crois plus qu'on puisse
le faire pour plein de raisons j'ai pas
développé et donc je finis juste mon
modèle à deux secteurs tu as ça tu
dégages énormément de richesses qui
ensuite te permet de financer un état
social efficace avec par exemple pour
prendre l'exemple des chômeurs des
allocations chômage élevées mais aussi
un contrôle très strict sur des chômeurs
tu forces les gens à changer de secteur
c'est avec l'économiste a toujours été
très dur à toujours été très
c'est un mot pourri mais dire
communautaire au sens où il y avait
l'idée de dire tu es effectivement
justement dans un pays qui était très
pauvre au début du 20e siècle justement
parce qu'il est pas de ressources
naturelles et qui s'est développé
énormément grâce à une notamment à
l'éducation tu es suédois tu as la
chance d'être en Suède tu fermes un peu
ta gueule tu fais le boulot qu'on dit
mais tu auras un bon boulot un bon
salaire de l'éducation gratuite de la
santé gratuite et ça a marché pendant
des décennies jusque disons il y a une
dizaine protestants là maintenant c'est
pour ça
alors débrouillez-vous tous les deux
regardez-vous
je voudrais juste réagir à trois choses
la première c'est que effectivement
personne ne sait d'où vient la création
monétaire c'est mais personne bon et je
bascule dans dans mon monteur
c'est la notion de la valeur et le
nombre de gens qui disent mais les
centaines de milliards qui vont
s'évaporer par rapport aux valorisations
etc je leur dis non elle ne s'évapore
pas elle n'avait jamais existé
et quand on voit effectivement
l'explosion des bulles et notamment les
dernières depuis 35 ans il faut
effectivement faire admettre à nos
auditeurs et au public non
cette valeur artificielle n'a jamais
existé donc ça c'était la première
élément le deuxième sur je pense que je
vis alors je suis désolé mais moi j'aime
bien un steak
pas tout le pas tous les jours mais de
temps en temps ça me fait vraiment un
immense plaisir je crois que la sobriété
était un problème d'éducation et
effectivement entre une creusoise qui
était
dans des pays durs et un catalan
également dans un pays dur on était
habitué à une certaine sobriété mais
durationnement oui à la limite du
rationnement or ce qui manque dans dans
ton éloge on va dire de cette sobriété
c'est le moteur de cette industrie
de je dirais de la vanité de l'apparence
etc
le vrai moteur j'ai dû conclure à peu
près 250 je sais pas si c'est 250 ou 300
transactions financières dans ma vie
d'accord si je regarde du pognon non
parce que parce que non d'abord parce
que j'étais à un niveau qui est entre
100 et 1000 fois inférieur à mes grands
à mes grands confrères et de très très
souvent je travaillais pas pro bono mais
vraiment
au minimum syndical mais
honnêtement la rationalité des
transactions que j'ai faites mais elle
est extrêmement rare
extrêmement rare le vrai désir d'aller
chercher une technologie ou un accès à
un marché etc non et mes grands
confrères de Londres de Francfort ou New
York me disent mais
le côté griggy et très souvent l'unique
c'est parce que j'ai un pistolet qui est
plus gros que le tien et je veux te le
démontrer donc cet éloge de la sobriété
vient se fracasser sur un côté on va
dire un petit peu
négatif et le troisième je l'ai oublié
donc je te passe la partie je rebondis
sur ce qu'on a à ce qu'on a dit à la
fois
sur l'éloge de la Suède alors je suis
entièrement d'accord je pense qu'il faut
il faut qu'on sorte il se rappelle non
non c'est que en fait je dis simplement
que le futur
il faut que le secteur
coopératif et associatif qui doit
représenter je sais pas 10 15% du PIB de
l'Occident
10%. il faut qu'il double
si on veut apaiser les choses il faut
que ce secteur or ça pose un énorme
problème et ça c'est mon appel à un
chantier qui me passionnerait c'est
comment apporter des fonds propres
à l'économie coopérative je ferme cette
parenthèse parce que c'est un vrai
gentil ça c'est le sujet des communs en
fait
je reviens je reviens un tout petit peu
sur la question de la transition et de
la sobriété et du modèle suédois alors
pour complètement aller dans ton sens
c'est-à-dire faire la transition alors
au moins énergétique il faut quand même
rappeler à tout le monde il y a un
aspect énergétique des carbonation et un
aspect proprement écologique au sens de
la biodiversité ça c'est arrêté
d'artificialiser les sols protéger nos
écosystèmes naturels etc c'est un peu
plus compliqué déjà puis un aspect et
ressources naturelles qui vont commencer
à manquer
concentrons-nous sur la question
énergétique donc le rapport de
l'Institut Rousseau de mars dernier 2%
pour 2 degrés qui chiffre à 2% le coût
de la transition conclut aussi comme tu
l'as dit que ça se passera beaucoup
mieux pour les Françaises et les
Français en 2050 si on le fait en
moyenne chaque ménage français économise
1500 euros par an si on fait cette
transition pourquoi parce qu'on va avoir
beaucoup moins de dépenses de santé on
sera moins malade on sera moins polluant
à Paris c'est incroyable d'ailleurs de
Paris est beaucoup beaucoup plus pollué
que celui de Washington par exemple etc
voilà donc effectivement tu as
absolument raison on gagne sur tous les
tableaux si on fait cette transition et
je pense que c'est fondamental qu'on
sorte de l'imaginaire triste dans lequel
la transition écologique est enfermée
c'est pas les amis je contre la
croissance verte pas du tout parce que
la transition écologique c'est pas les
amis si au contraire un monde beaucoup
plus désirable socialement beaucoup plus
épanoui parce que ce qui compte c'est
pas la croissance du PIB en fait on a la
strictement rien à faire la croissance
du PIB si je fais un accident de voiture
dans la sur l'autoroute j'augmente le
pied ce qui compte c'est le niveau
d'éducation
oui et l'OCDE avait proposé en 2014
qu'on introduise la prostitution dans le
pied pour faire gonfler que le PIB voilà
ce qui dit l'aberration totale de la
[Musique]
constitutions
et moi je crois qu'ils ont obtenu gain
de cause particulier en partie
d'indicateurs Eurostat je me demande
s'ils sont pas
je crois pas mais bon peut-être donc la
question c'est plus l'augmentation du
PIB c'est le niveau d'éducation la
qualité de vie l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé ce sont alors c'est ça les
grands indicateurs qui doivent piloter
pour nous la transition on sait la faire
on l'a déjà dit on sait la financer donc
c'est ça le vrai projet politique à la
de tous les progressistes aujourd'hui
c'est ça qu'il faudrait mettre en oeuvre
il faut fiscaliser un peu l'église ou
pas fiscaliser l'église qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire quand je donne dans le tronc
est-ce qu'il faut que l'État récupère un
petit peu non c'est un don que tu fais
au Seigneur c'est ça non c'est un don
qui est non non non
patrimoine de l'église ça c'est un autre
sujet il y a ça par exemple c'est un
vrai sujet pour la Grèce au moment où la
Grèce explose en 2010 l'Église orthodoxe
grec procède probablement la moitié du
patrimoine immobilier grec un tiers au
moins un tiers voilà et elle n'a pas
fait grand chose pour aider dans la
société grecque donc là c'est un vrai
sujet je suis d'accord c'est pas du tout
le cas en France c'est pas du tout voilà
mais parce qu'en France on est la
Révolution française est passée par là
1905 c'est passé par là etc on est dans
une situation complètement différente
tu voulais rebondir ou je tiens je calme
ma question est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
avec toutes ces inflation cette crise
énergétique je vais faire le candidat
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
à une économie de rationnement façon
Soviet pendant les mauvaises années
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que on
se fasse
tondre par l'inflation est-ce que cette
nouvelle taxe qui est l'inflation va
tondre les classes moyennes
éradiquer les classes moyennes est-ce
que vous en tant que économiste ou
travailler dans les marchés financiers
où on saignant
l'économie est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
à ce que ce soit à l'ancienne avec des
tickets de rationnement des choses comme
ça moi je suis né dans une période
d'inflation j'ai commencé à travailler
dans une
1855 c'était en 1870 72
je touchais ah non pas du tout pas du
tout je suis l'aîné de toute façon moi
je me suis arrêté à 42 ans
j'ai 42 ans moi je l'aurais jusqu'à la
jusqu'à ma mort
donc j'ai 42 ans et point barre mais
le merde
l'inflation l'inflation est un problème
et donc on vivait avec l'inflation
à condition si si on vivait
Nancy attends un couple d'ouvriers
dans les années
75-80 à Paris vivait dignement vivez
dignement avec ces deux trois gosses
d'accord ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui donc donc donc
mais son salaire augmenté dans cette
période-là de 10% parce que les prix
augmentaient de 10 % etc etc
quel est le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui
il y a dans mon univers du monde de
l'investissement une espèce de de
panique
sur je m'occupais énormément d'une
association
qui s'appelle comment qui s'appelle
l'envol et qui accueille des enfants
c'est les techniques de cyrule unique de
la résilience appliquée à des enfants
qui ont des maladies létales et qui
n'ont aucune ressource d'accord donc on
aide les enfants etc et ça fait 15 ans
que je m'occupe à fond de cette
association nous avons 12 permanents et
la patronne de ces 12 permanents dit je
vais augmenter les salaires dans le
conseil d'administration qui est comme
toutes les belles associations dans
l'univers des gens riches et aisés
hostilité ah non non non non il faut
attendre et la directrice de cette
association dit mais non on a des jeunes
collaboratrices qui sont des femmes
remarquables essentiellement des femmes
on a des femmes remarquables il faut on
les aide en augmentant les salaires
d'accord pourquoi cette hostilité parce
que si l'inflation se propage
elle met un néant
l'imposture de la création de valeur
d'accord donc que ce soit de Bruxelles
Londres ou autre il y a une volonté de
surtout éviter que cette inflation se
passe des coups au salaire puis des
salaires au cou
ce qui à mon avis n'est pas justifié
dans la mesure où comme nous connaissons
aujourd'hui les mécanismes on pourrait
le laisser filer pendant 2 3 4 ans et
puis petit à petit doucement revenir
plutôt qu'effectivement
accélérer accélérer les drames que nous
allons connaître donc l'inflation à mon
avis
effectivement va donner un sacré coup de
rabot dans la mesure où les medefs
français et internationaux
il faut surtout pas
propager le phénomène de l'inflation
donc contrainte
dans l'immédiat oui alors il faut
pardon pardon de rappeler ça mais dans
la réalité économique il y a des choses
qu'on peut mesurer directement et
d'autres non et juste pour rappeler
quand même comment ça se passe tout ça
quand vous êtes effectivement quand vous
êtes mettons que Gael Giraud soit
ministre de l'Économie et ce qu'il
aimerait savoir en fait c'est quelle est
la production de la France c'est-à-dire
combien en fait de pots de yaourt de
voiture de caméras de table etc bon il
peut le savoir mais vous doutez bien que
si on lui fait la liste de tout ce qui
est produit en France tous les jours ça
va faire des centaines des centaines de
pages donc qu'est-ce qui va observer il
va observer les ventes il va observer
les ventes c'est-à-dire les prix
multipliés par les quantités et donc là
on va voir un chiffre et c'est le fameux
c'est le fameux PIB mais évidemment ce
chiffre est gênant par le fait que par
exemple donc sur son bureau de ministre
de l'économie il va voir que le PIB
augmente mais s'il ne regarde que le PIB
il n'a aucun moyen il faut bien
comprendre il n'a aucun moyen de savoir
si ce sont les quantités qui augmentent
si ce sont les prix qui augmentent ou si
ce sont les deux ou si ce sont même les
prix qui baissent et les quantités qui
augmentent beaucoup plus donc toute
voyez elle fait beaucoup de combinaisons
possibles donc ce problème qui est connu
depuis toujours c'est un problème en
fait comme c'est ta manière qui est
insurmontable c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre et donc on a une solution
c'est qu'on va conduire un indice des
prix et donc un indice des prix si la
création humaine c'est-à-dire qu'on va
sélectionner un certain nombre de biens
dans l'économie donc ça c'est pas très
problématique surtout aujourd'hui on
peut l'Insee recense effectivement des
dizaines ou des centaines de milliers de
prix tous les jours à la fois dans
l'économie physique haute et aussi sur
Internet bien sûr le prix du beurre
dedans le prix de la viande
beaucoup plus que ça tu rigoles la
viande de bœuf de porc les différents
morceaux non ça c'est impressionnant
là-dessus il y a pas trop de mise à part
évidemment l'économie souterraine là il
y a pas trop de débats là dessus mais la
question c'est la pondération la
pondération c'est-à-dire que quelle part
quand tu as conduire ton indice tu vas
avoir un seul chiffre tu veux pas avoir
tous les prix de tous les biens et donc
tu as pondéré et donc on l'a déjà
expliqué mais ça me permet de revenir
là-dessus
un des problèmes majeurs c'est que le
logement est très largement sous-estimé
dans ce fameux indice des prix puisque
pour des raisons théoriques théoriques
on revient toujours la théorie on ne
prend en compte que l'évolution des
loyers et on ne prend pas en compte
notamment l'évolution du coût réel de
logement des gens qui empruntent alors
quelle est l'explication c'est de dire
lorsque vous achetez votre logement nous
les économistes on considère que c'est
un investissement que ça n'est pas une
consommation et donc ça sort de l'indice
des prix à la consommation précisément
et donc on a cette indice qui en fait
est faux depuis toujours alors c'était
pas très gênant lorsque les prix de
l'immobilier augmentait de comme un peu
près comme les autres prix mais c'est
très très gênant depuis facilement de
voir trois décennies et donc par exemple
on trouve facilement ces sidérant il y a
meilleures agents le site meilleur agent
qui a fait une étude sur qu'est-ce qu'on
peut acheter quand on est un jeune enfin
dans quoi est-ce qu'on peut se loger
pardon il s'agit de loyer un pas d'achat
lorsque on est un jeune diplômé dans une
ville il montre que dans des villes
comme Toulouse comme Dijon vous avez
perdu une pièce en 20 ans il est perdu
une pièce donc c'est une chute massive
de votre niveau de vie et on pourrait
dire la dame de l'économie c'est une
augmentation très importante de
l'inflation mais moi ce que j'aimerais
effectivement ce qu'on n'arrive pas du
tout à faire nos économistes mais en
fait je vois que la société plus
généralement en tout cas les gens qui
nous dirigent c'est ce qui a déjà dit
Gaëlle Giro c'est qu'il faut revenir à
la base matérielle c'est-à-dire que non
seulement effectivement on va être
rationné sur ce qu'on peut acheter parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est que l'inflation
l'inflation c'est de dire pour le même
budget je vais acheter moins qu'avant
c'est ça l'inflation puisqu'il y a plus
les prix augmentent donc les quantités
que moi ce que je vais pouvoir acheter
mon quantité de beurre de tartines je
rinkification exactement il y a même une
publicité pour une marque de supermarché
qui joue avec ça on voit que les gens
n'ont pas le bien enfin on voit un gars
qui se verse un bol de céréales mais il
a pas de lait il a pas de céréales il a
pas de bol c'est la fin du monde bon
donc mais il y a effectivement la
question de l'eau la question des
ressources matérielles et qui qui va
manquer on le sait tous et là aussi on
effectivement baigne tellement dans
cette idéologie du progrès dans un
mauvais sens du terme je crois vraiment
piéger par tous ces termes c'est comme
libéral progrès il faudrait très très
vite retravailler ces termes-là que on
n'arrive pas à comprendre que nous la
France on est soumis à des contraintes
matérielles qui en plus je pense
s'oppose très violemment l'esprit
français qui a toujours détesté la
matière la réalité et je donne juste un
exemple pour terminer je trouve ça mais
grotesque à se taper le cul par terre ou
alors vraiment à se flinguer quand je
vois Agnès bannière une hachée qui se
félicite qui en plus ne sera pas mis en
oeuvre que les enseignes lumineuses je
sais pas si vous avez vu ça les
anciennes lumineuses des magasins vont
désormais être éteinte entre une heure
et 6h du matin
voilà et elle est contente de ça donc
non seulement elle est contente de ça
d'autre part ce qu'on voit très très
nettement dans le plan sobriété du
gouvernement c'est que c'est évident
dans leur tête que c'est temporaire
c'est la magie c'est à dire qu'ils ont
tellement pas compris
l'incroyable morsure l'incroyable
morsure de la contrainte écologique de
la contrainte énergétique sur nos villes
les plus quotidiennes exactement enfin
on l'a dit on en est à parler de la
question du manque d'eau et eux ils
arrivent même pas à comprendre que les
minuscules restrictions qui mettent en
place mais évidemment c'est pour
toujours les amis et que même si on
était juste un peu moins débile les
anciennes lumineuses bah c'est fini ça a
pas existé pendant 99% de l'histoire de
l'humanité bon on s'est bien marré avec
ça et c'est fini les enceintes
lumineuses mais qu'on soit même pas
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a la guerre en
Europe que le gouvernement est en
panique qu'on a le président de la
République qui nous dit on espère qu'on
va passer divers comme on dit d'une
personne très âgée que on espère qu'elle
va passer l'hiver on en est là à
utiliser cette expression à la tête de
l'État et ils sont pas foutus de prendre
la moindre mesure ne serait-ce que voilà
de faire que les anciens lumineux soient
juste éteinte la nuit quoi c'est à dire
je sais pas de 19h à 8h ou 9h du matin
Gaëlle toi tu vas bien passé l'hiver aux
États-Unis ça va être pépouse dehors aux
États-Unis effectivement sur la question
des ce que tu as dit est très très juste
sur la question des prix du
caractéristique de la construction d'un
indice des prix alors il y a
effectivement l'omission énorme du
marché immobilier il y a aussi un petit
aspect technique je le dis pour ceux que
ces aspects ces questions intéressantes
qui est la valorisation par exemple des
ordinateurs et le la question de savoir
qu'une question qui se repose chaque
année chez nos comptables nationaux
est-ce que l'augmentation du prix de
l'ordinateur est lié à une augmentation
de la qualité de l'ordinateur qu'elle
n'avait pas d'inflation ou est-ce que en
fait cette augmentation du prix c'est
juste quelqu'un qui a augmenté ses
marges alors que l'ordinateur rend les
mêmes services cette année que l'année
précédente voilà il y a des il y a des
débats absolument Byzantins sur ces
questions là je referme cette parenthèse
un autre aspect un tout petit peu
technique mais ça va intéresser
j'imagine ce qui nous écoutent ce qui
est que
dans ce qu'on fait les économistes une
fois qu'on a calculé le PIB nominal ce
que tu as ce que tu as rappelé donc les
transactions fois la valeur de cette
transaction on a calculé un indice des
prix on déflate le PIB nominal de cette
indice des prix et on en déduit ce qu'on
appelle un PIB réel et ce que alors qui
est confondu avec la taille du gâteau le
thème du gâteau c'est pas le pays béret
mais bon on a l'habitude a été prise de
croire que la taille du gâteau France
c'est le PIB réel alors le paradoxe
c'est que ce PIB réel quand on le
calcule par exemple entre maintenant et
dans 5 ans et bien en réalité on utilise
le même indice des prix entre maintenant
et dans cinq ans or l'indice des prix a
complètement changé en cinq ans il y a
l'état d'un certain nombre de produits
qui se sont appréciés d'autres qui se
sont dépréciés etc or donc on fait cette
fiction que les prix relatifs restent
constants donc le PIB réel à 5 ans n'a
aucun sens absolument aucun sens déjà le
PIB réels aujourd'hui n'a pas beaucoup
mais alors le PIB l a 5 ans ne renvoie à
aucune réalité aucune existence
économique je referme cette parenthèse
juste un mot également sur la question
de l'inflation
je pense il faut aussi quand même
distinguer entre l'inflation que connaît
aujourd'hui par exemple la Turquie qui a
300% à l'année ou que connaît le Liban
et donc qui commence à s'emballer dans
une hyper inflation qui est extrêmement
douloureuse pour la totalité du corps
social et l'inflation que nous avons
aujourd'hui alors elle fait mal mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec les pères inflation
premièrement deuxièmement je crois que
ce que tu as des rafales et tout à fait
juste le grand sujet c'est les salaires
si les salaires suivent l'inflation
n'est pas une si mauvaise chose et j'ai
souvenir de quelqu'un comme Olivier
Blanchard lorsqu'il était chef
économiste du FMI qui disait mais
peut-être qu'au lieu d'avoir une target
d'inflation donc un objectif d'inflation
à 2% nos banques centrales pourrait
avoir un objectif d'inflation à 4 donc 4
c'était pour lui c'était pas péché voilà
si les salaires suivent l'inflation
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait essentiellement
elle rogne ce qu'on appelle le fixe
incom en anglais c'est-à-dire les
revenus fixes de ceux qui sont riches et
qui ont acheté des obligations par
exemple de la dette et qui attendent
simplement d'avoir les intérêts sur la
dette voilà alors ces intérêts là ils
sont nominaux il très peu d'obligations
indexées sur l'inflation en tout cas en
Europe beaucoup plus aux États-Unis et
donc l'inflation rogne s'est revenu là
mais ces revenus là c'est des revenus de
personnes favorisées et en général âgé
donc en fait la phobie
anti-inflationniste typiquement
allemande par exemple il y a des
vieilles racines c'est un choix
politique quand on choisit de lutter
contre l'inflation on choisit d'opter
pour le chômage puisqu'en réalité d'un
point de vue économique en vérité il y a
un vrai dilemme inflation chômage
contrairement à ce qui a été raconté par
beaucoup de néoclassiques si on veut pas
l'inflation on aura du chômage si on
veut lutter contre le chômage il faut
accepter un petit peu l'inflation à
condition que ça dégénère pas en hyper
inflation à la libanaise ou à la nature
qu'aujourd'hui un de vous deux qu'est-ce
qui peut m'expliquer ce que c'est un
choc Volker
ah oui ben je l'ai enseigné la semaine
dernière je crois donc j'étais pas là
ouais ça c'est voici une de mes
histoires préférées même si elle est
très triste alors
plein plein de choses à dire alors donc
Paul Walker
dirigeant de la Banque centrale des
États-Unis donc on appelle la fête à la
Fédérale réserve et alors c'est vrai
dans les choses très mystérieuses de
l'économie on a parlé de des banques qui
créent de l'argent à partir de rien
alors les banques centrales c'est encore
pire parce qu'elles on peut dire que
vraiment elle crée de l'argent mais
alors vraiment vraiment à partir de rien
il a aussi c'est plus que problématique
que ce soit pas enseigné au collège ou
au lycée et en plus elles ont un
deuxième pouvoir les banques centrales
c'est qu'elle fixe de façon totalement
mais totalement souveraine le niveau des
taux d'intérêt en tout cas le niveau du
taux d'intérêt le plus important dans
l'économie parce qu'en fait il y a plein
taux d'intérêt dans l'économie le taux
d'intérêt pour si on vous prête l'argent
à 6 mois c'est pas le même que si on
fait un prêt immobilier pendant 30 ans
le prêt immobilier pour la consommation
pour la voiture c'est pas le même que le
prix immobilier donc les gens savent
qu'il y a différents prêts
alors et donc Paul Walker 1979 nous
sommes en 1979 il y a eu deux chocs
pétroliers 73 et 79 l'inflation je crois
est à 15 % aux États-Unis elle va même
atteindre les 20 % et Paul Walker il se
dit il se dit que sa mission dans la vie
c'est de tuer l'inflation et donc il va
y arriver et ce qui va faire c'est qu'il
va aussi tuer entre guillemets les
Américains c'est à dire que il va faire
exploser les taux d'intérêt qui va
chômage voilà qui va qui va porter à
20%, mais ce qu'il faut savoir et ce qui
est fou c'est que il le fait pour créer
du chômage il le fait pour créer du
chemin et donc ça marche puis évidemment
lorsque le taux d'intérêt sont très
élevé qu'est-ce qui se passe les gens ne
demandent plus de crédit parce que vous
pouvez pas rembourser donc les
entreprises arrêtent d'investir les
ménages arrêtent d'acheter des voitures
aux États-Unis par crédit et les ménages
arrêtent d'acheter des logements donc en
fait vous cassez la demande de crédit
donc vous cassez l'activité économique
donc vous cassez la production donc vous
créez du chômage donc les gens qui ont
du travail on en a parlé tout à l'heure
peur donc ils arrêtent de demander des
augmentations salariales et donc vous
obtenez avec d'autres facteurs mais je
fais cours effectivement la
ralentissement de l'inflation qui va
chuter très brutalement au début des
années 80 aux États-Unis et ce que je
dis juste c'est là que la question de
l'internaute est excellente c'est que
nous avons des déclarations pardon
excusez-moi excusez-moi monsieur je
la voulais bon et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on a Jérôme
Powell donc il est l'actuel on aura
beaucoup parlé de la Banque centrale des
États-Unis ce soir Jérôme paolel qui est
l'actuel président de directeur de la
Banque centrale États-Unis qui a fait
des déclarations il y a quelques mois
hallucinantes qu'on retrouve très
facilement dans la presse française où
il nous dit que lui aussi il souhaite
créer du chômage lui aussi pour briser
l'inflation et donc il a très fortement
augmenté des taux d'intérêt des
États-Unis ce qui a forcé notre cher
Christine Lagarde à faire de même en
Europe et là ce qui est fou ce qui est
absolument fou c'est que tout le monde
comprend tout le monde comprend pourquoi
il y a de l'inflation c'est pour des
causes écologiques énergétiques
diplomatique qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les phénomènes monétaires et donc c'est
complètement non non là c'est
complètement absurde alors là je suis
désolé c'est pas en tout cas je pense je
pense que c'est complètement ce qu'a
fait Voltaire c'est-à-dire que ça avait
du sens c'était
en train de dire que tu es américain
salut
il a obtenu son objectif c'était un
moyen qui permettait au prix d'une case
sociale terrible mais c'était cohérent
actuellement l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt à la fois par la Banque
centrale d'américaine la Banque centrale
européenne n'aura aucun effet sur le
prix du gaz n'aura aucun effet sur le
prix du gaz donc c'est complètement fou
voilà
on règle l'inflation
délibérément et de façon cynique par une
récession
organisée d'accord alors concernant
l'inflation
ayant compte ayant été un petit
contributeur mais un contributeur à
cette bulle de la création de valeur
pour confesser un prêtre
je
comment dirais-je mais même si je n'aime
pas trop les recommandations de Milton
Friedman je pense qu'il y a une part de
vérité alors quelle est la vraie part de
vérité
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de débats
c'est que quand il y a eu une telle
création de valeur artificielle c'est à
dire une inflation des actifs
financiers de dette et immobiliers je ne
vois pas comment un processus
inflationniste n'allait pas arriver à un
moment ou à un autre voilà mais voilà
bon alors pour profilman il considère
que effectivement l'inflation n'est que
un processus monétaire moi je dis
simplement quand je vois cette cette
absurdité ce que j'appelle c'est un
posture de de créer des survalleurs qui
n'ont plus rien à voir avec l'économie
réelle
il fallait qu'à un moment ou un autre ça
se traduise pourquoi mais c'est parce
que l'écosystème que je représente ce
soir lui c'est considérablement enrichi
et quand je le vois au niveau des
salaires de tout cet écosystème mais on
est on est dans la des raisons je veux
dire qu'un garçon de 28 ans simplement
parce qu'il est brillant avec sa trousse
à outils financière et le salaire d'un
chirurgien cardiaque en fin de carrière
à l'hôpital de Purpan il y a un
déséquilibre dans l'offre et de la
demande d'emploi qui est totale je crois
que ça fait longtemps que tu t'es pas
renseigné sur le salaire du chirurgien
la situation il doit gagner même pas un
dixième de ce que prend un trader
il gagne ce que l'autre gagne à 28 ans
donc
voilà enfin bon donc voilà donc
l'inflation était quand même un petit
peu
réparer
était déjà une erreur à l'époque
l'inflation de la fin des années 70
c'est essentiellement les deux chocs
pétroliers étaient déjà tirées par
l'énergie à l'époque Volker et les
monétaristes font une erreur qu'on a
laissé décrire c'est-à-dire de croire
que l'inflation est un phénomène
monétaire et que l'augmentation du
niveau des prix c'est l'augmentation de
la monnaie en circulation ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure je multiplie par de
la monnaie ça augmente les prix ce qui
est ce qu'il faut donc il se dit bah on
va diminuer la quantité de monnaie en
circulation et pour ça on va rendre la
monnaie cher on augmente le taux
d'intérêt voilà et comme la très bien
rigide et tue l'économie américaine
effectivement l'inflation baisse c'est
comme si vous avez quelqu'un qui a de la
fièvre vous tuez celui qui a de la
fièvre il a plus de fièvre mais il est
mort voilà donc aujourd'hui on est en
train de refaire la même erreur tragique
on peut dire quand même à l'actif de
Christine Lagarde qu'elle a été beaucoup
plus lente que la Fed a augmenté les
taux du course du course vous avez pas
vu ça
pour une raison à mon avis qui est que
la BCE c'est très bien que les banques
européennes sont beaucoup plus fragile
que les banques américaines aujourd'hui
les banques américaines se sont
recaptées après 2009 les nôtres beaucoup
moins et que si on augmente les taux
trop vite on risque de provoquer un
krach boursier donc c'est aussi pour
protéger nos banques européennes que
Festina garde va plus lentement et je
pense que la tuer la raison évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'il est zone prendre de la
fièvre aussi ce con
tu veux rajouter des choses
économique c'est que ce qui me gêne
énormément dans la toute la discussion
médiatique actuelle à propos de
l'inflation et reportage absolument
incroyable au 20 heures de France 2 il y
a quelques temps on nous parlait de
l'augmentation du prix du pétrole
augmentation du prix de la nourriture et
jamais jamais la personne qui a augmenté
ses prix de vente n'est présente et ça
c'est un énorme problème alors là la
discipline des économistes est pleine
totalement coupable c'est que les prix
augmentent tout seul et ça je pense que
c'est un énorme problème démocratique
l'industrie lui aussi obligé de
récupérer
ma casquette de journaliste si je fais
un article sur l'inflation je dois
expliquer quelle prix augmente et qui
augmente je n'ai aucun problème avec le
fait que l'agriculteur dans les
rendements ont baissé à cause de la
sécheresse évidemment je souhaite de
toute façon j'explique qui doit
augmenter son prix de vente du lait et
moi je suis pour le coup très content de
lui payer plus cher son lait au
supermarché ça me pose aucun prêt mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que la fameuse
peur effectivement des fameuses spirales
inflationnistes pourquoi est-ce qu'elles
ne peuvent pas exister aujourd'hui pour
deux raisons très profondes c'est que en
fait dans l'économie mondialisée et la
mondialisation a été activement alors
c'est très très clair créé par les
institutions internationales
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce il y
a des tas de textes des années 90
justement pour briser l'inflation c'est
que si moi j'ai un truc à vendre
qu'est-ce qui me permet d'augmenter mon
prix et de continuer à vendre parce que
c'est ça le truc c'est facile
d'augmenter mon prix mais si plus
personne n'achètent ça m'a servi à rien
donc qu'est-ce qui me permet d'augmenter
mon prix et de continuer à vendre c'est
que j'ai pas de concurrent Renaud dans
les années 70 quand attendait 6 mois
pour avoir ta R18 comme mon père il l'a
eu tu payais le prix qu'il fallait payer
parce que tu pouvais pas acheter une
voiture japonaise c'était une bonne
caisse c'était une break qui a été
vraiment génial bon et donc aujourd'hui
les entreprises françaises même Renault
aujourd'hui ne peut plus fixer son prix
de vente ne peut plus du tout et
d'ailleurs le Renault va se faire
massacrer sur le domaine de l'électrique
par les voitures chin qu'on va acheter
avec l'argent de l'État français qui va
nous filer Emmanuel Macron là c'est
juste absolument magnifique c'est la
magie voilà et donc en économie on
distingue ce qu'on appelle les agents
qui sont preneurs de prix c'est-à-dire
que les gens qui subissent le prix qui
leur est fixé par la concurrence et ceux
qui sont qui sont faiseur de prix
c'est-à-dire Apple Apple il peut plus ou
moins encore vendre ses iPhone 10 fois
trop cher même si même là c'est pas
totalement vrai mais il le peut parce
qu'il y a des gens qui rêvent d'avoir un
iPhone on le sait tout bon et donc du
côté des salariés ce que pouvait faire
les salariés des années 70 ils ont eu
des augmentations salariales vous en
parliez parce que il y avait la CGT
parce qu'il y avait le plein d'emploi
parce qu'il y avait le Parti communiste
parce qu'il y avait l'Union soviétique
aujourd'hui il est bien évident que les
salariés nulle part sur la planète à
part peut-être quelques exceptions ne
peuvent plus obtenir massivement des
hausses salaires ça n'est plus possible
et donc comme on a à la fois et donc le
point commun de tout ça enfin sauf par
des processus politiques mais si on
laisse l'économie fonctionner toute
seule ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on a
une très forte concurrence au niveau des
entreprises qui est largement
internationale voire mondial pour
beaucoup d'entreprises et d'autre part
on a une concurrence une précarité
tellement forte dans le monde du travail
qu'on a aussi une concurrence entre les
salariés qui est d'ailleurs accrue par
les réformes actuelles notamment de
baisse des allocations chômage et donc
ce que je veux dire juste en terme de
mécanisme c'est que la fameuse spirale
prix salaire qui a existé dans les
années 70 et je suis entièrement
d'accord avec dont l'unique source
effectivement était en fait écologique
c'est à dire que moi ce que nous a pas
enseigné dans notre génération c'est que
le choc pétrolier que nous a toujours
présenté comme question géopolitique ou
après une question économique c'est la
première grande crise écologique de
l'histoire contemporaine mais ce terme
n'était pas utilisé il faut relire cette
histoire c'était la première grande
crise écologique qui ensuite enchaîné à
entraîner une spirale prix salaire qui
ne peut plus avoir lieu aujourd'hui et
que donc de ce point de vue là
effectivement évidemment qu'il faut que
les salaires augmentent autant que
l'inflation qui ne peut pas encore avoir
qui ne peut plus avoir lieu parce que la
ressource énergétique est contrainte
non non je parlais juste des prix et des
salaires du fait de la concurrence du
fait de la concurrence qui a à la fois
au niveau des entreprises au niveau du
salariat par contre effectivement à plus
longue échéance et là c'est quelque
chose qui est mal compris c'est que la
contrainte écologique et je parle pas
des politiques écologiques mais de la
contrainte naturelle l'écologie en fait
la contrainte naturelle que c'est une
chute de la productivité c'est une
augmentation des coûts de production par
exemple pour la première fois dans
l'histoire récente l'année dernière la
récolte mondiale de lait et la baissé on
sait que dans les tentates tout un tas
de céréales les rendements baisse on
sait que évidemment les ressources
fossiles vont coûter de plus en plus
cher et donc si on laisse et c'est là
effectivement c'est là le danger
vraiment pour nos démocraties c'est que
si on laisse le système économique
fonctionnait tout seul on est face à une
chute brutale de la productivité c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre quand on manque
d'eau quand on manque de céréales parce
que c'est la nature entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire le conflit entre la nature
et notre système économique qui fait
chuter la productivité et là vous en
supplice il y a un livre à lire c'est
Jean Fourastier les 30 GLOR
les livres c'est à la fin bon
vient de faire référence à un élément
que j'ai vécu puisque j'avais en face de
moi
un garçon qui qui était dans les
Jeunesses communistes
françaises etc et qui effectivement
demandait des augmentations de salaire
régulière il faut savoir que dans
l'univers de l'investissement que je
représente ce soir sur ce plateau
une des raisons qui est inquiétante
c'est que ils partent du principe que
depuis
Francis lucuyama etc c'est fini il n'y a
plus de rêve marxiste socialiste donc en
réalité
on est peinard on est peinard il n'y a
plus de tendance
il n'y a plus de légitimité
donc à partir du moment où il n'y a plus
de d'idéologie on peut faire ce qu'on
veut
oui c'est vrai donc ça c'est publié son
livre sur la fin de l'histoire après la
chute du mur juste pour compléter ce que
tu as dit Gilles en 1973 donc on a le
premier chapitre pétrolier
en fait ça venait trois ans après la
découverte complètement effarée par
l'administration américaine du fait que
les grandes puits pétroliers américains
qui avaient été découvert dans les
années 20 et les années 30 qui avait
assuré la prospérité américaine avait
atteint leur pic d'extraction dès 1970
et que donc les Américains comprenaient
que désormais ils n'arriverait plus à
augmenter la quantité de pétrole qui
pouvait extraire du sous-sol sur leur
territoire donc il fallait apporter la
démocratie aux autres voilà donc il
fallait donc ils allaient dépendre du
pétrole à l'extérieur et juste à ce
moment là l'OPE qui comprend ça joue
là-dessus dans un contexte ou
probablement pour la première fois on
atteint le point d'inflexion de la
courbe de productivité au sens de l'iroy
le rendement énergétique la quantité
d'énergie qu'il faut pour laisser un
énergie on atteint un premier point
d'inflexion la grande question que ça
nous pose aujourd'hui à mon avis il y en
a deux par rapport à notre débat en ce
moment c'est comment est-ce qu'on
contrôle les prix en France
et on a en fait on a un dispositif qui
existe déjà pour les DOM-TOM qui
s'appelle le bouclier
qualité prix le bqp donc c'est le préfet
qui discutant avec les les parties
prenantes de sa préfecture fixent les
prix d'un certain nombre de biens de
première nécessité dans sa sur son
territoire et on pourrait très bien
étendre à l'Hexagone le bqp qui
fonctionne très très bien depuis des
décennies dans le DOM-TOM ça c'est pour
l'inflation et ça sur l'énergie le gaz
le pétrole oui bien sûr la Commission
européenne va proposer un blocage des
prix d'énergie
et donc et donc l'énergie elle va aller
se vendre ailleurs non peut-être non pas
du tout les énergies ont absolument
besoin de vendre des énergies à l'Europe
qui reste le plus gros marché du monde
aujourd'hui ils ont absolument besoin de
nous et donc et deuxièmement le
à mon avis l'autre point central qu'il
faut dire c'est la grande question qui
nous est posée à plusieurs milliers de
milliards c'est est-ce qu'on a atteint
le pic d'extraction du pétrole au niveau
mondial aujourd'hui toute l'équipe
confondues donc on a atteint au niveau
avec les techniques conventionnelles
entre 2006 et 2008
il est possible qu'on atteigne dans
cette décennie
ce que ça va signifier c'est qu'il sera
impossible à partir de ce moment-là
d'augmenter la quantité de pétrole qu'on
extrait du sous-sol même avec les
fracturations hydrauliques de la roche
etc même avec le pétrole de schiste et
voilà si on continue de dépendre
massivement du pétrole comme on n'en
dépend aujourd'hui en particulier pour
la mobilité ça veut dire qu'il y a plus
de prospérité possible il y a plus de
monnaie s'il peut y avoir de la monnaie
qui sera de la monnaie de singe qui sera
une monnaie qui sera plus grand chose
d'où les perles inflation qu'on a par
exemple au Liban
pour acheter un verre de thé au Liban
c'est ce qui est ce qui était
l'équivalent d'un mois de salaire il y a
quelques années c'est complètement fou
donc la grande question si on veut
éviter ça si on veut éviter l'image un
peu apocalyptique que tu décrivais tout
à l'heure du rationnement en France etc
bon qu'à mon avis il va pas tout à fait
se passer comme ça mais la société ça va
c'est pas à mon avis si on ne fait
toujours rien et qu'on continue de
détruire l'état social et comprend
aucune mesure pour avancer du côté de la
transition écologique c'est la voie
libanaise
c'est à dire une détérioration
progressive à la fois de la démocratie
libanaise des institutions politiques de
l'économie libanaise la fuite des
cerveaux et des jeunes qui quittent le
pays depuis des années donc diasporal
libanaise qui est plus puissante
aujourd'hui que l'économie base sur le
territoire et à la fin gigantesque
hold-up du Liban réalisé par le secteur
bancaire libanais qui a transféré une
partie des ressources monétaires
libanaises en Suisse avec les yeux
fermés de la communauté internationale
moi j'ai participé à une réunion au FMI
en 2017 probablement sur la crise
libanais c'était très clair pour toutes
les parties prenantes autour de la table
que l'économie libanaise avait
s'effondrer que la seule chose qui
tenait encore debout c'était la banque
centrale mais que la banque centrale
avait organisé un ce qu'on appelle une
pyramide de Ponzi c'est-à-dire que pour
récupérer des réserves dont elle avait
besoin pour maintenir la devise
libanaise elle empruntait auprès de la
diaspora libanaise elle empruntait à a
lorsqu'il fallait rembourser à Anne
emprunter à B etc ça s'appelle une
pyramide c'est complètement interdit et
on sait qu'une pyramide de Ponzi se
termine toujours par librement toujours
donc en réalité dès 2017 ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au Liban était parfaitement
prévisible la communauté internationale
la France en particulier la strict rien
fait donc maintenant on va donner des
leçons au libanais pour leur expliquer
la vie mais ils savent très bien que la
France en réalité a laissé tomber le
Liban depuis 2017
et ce temps est gagné par le secteur
bancaire libanais pour transférer une
partie de ses ressources hors du pays
donc c'est ça à mon avis le scénario
qu'il faut éviter à tout prix et qui
nous paronait surtout si entre temps on
est passé à la monnaie digitale qui fera
les délices du secteur bancaire français
Raphaël est-ce que
il faut que nous les français on dégage
de l'euro est-ce qu'il faut qu'on se
positionne sur du dollar est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il se positionne sur du franc
suisse est-ce qu'il faut qu'on se
positionne alors sans donner de conseils
d'investissement bien entendu je ne
donnerai pas non non est-ce que ce que
des cris Gaëlle par rapport à la
libanisation de la France
est-ce qu'il faut avoir des mesures
proactives tout de suite pour pouvoir
reconstruire le pays derrière est-ce que
tu comprends ce que je dis est-ce que
c'est bien
alors d'abord je n'ai jamais fait de
gestion de patrimoine de ma vie parce
que je reconnais que c'est un métier
particulièrement aucun conseil à suivre
ok on est d'accord
l'AMF je vais pas me mettre me mettre en
défaut par rapport à ça
par contre quel est pour moi le problème
c'est que
en fait ce qu'on est en train de dire
avec chacun sa sensibilité et son
expertise c'est que je pense qu'on est
on est d'accord tous les trois c'est
qu'effectivement le la production
socialement
utile de bien et de services
n'est plus suffisante pour assurer n'est
plus suffisante pour assurer je dirais
la cohésion sociale je suis extrêmement
heureux que Gaëlle ait donné ce chiffre
que moi je connaissais mais je ne
l'avais jamais entendu exprimé de façon
aussi catégorique c'est que en
équivalent temps plein oui il y a 30% de
chômeurs en France d'accord donc pour
tout entre guillemets les arrogants de
mon écosystème qui disent mais tout va
bien puisque on est en pleine emploi nos
messieurs et moi ce que toi tu décris je
le vis quand je vais à Compiègne à Laval
à Périgueux voir mes patrons
d'entreprise
donc à partir du moment où pour éviter
le drame de la libanisation en réalité
ma recommandation c'est de dire
affranchi son nous de la croissance du
PIB
qui est qui ne sert plus à rien c'est
une douceur obsolète
et regardons
l'activité socialement
utile je j'aime ce mot je suis un homme
de l'entreprise j'aime ce mot de l'objet
social
l'objet social je suis très gênant de ce
point de vue là dire que je considère
que le
but de l'entreprise et de répondre aux
attentes des parties prenantes c'est le
jeu de mots en anglais entre le steak
odeur qui est le la partie prenante et
le stockholder qui est l'actionnaire les
steckolders c'est quoi c'est les clients
c'est les fournisseurs c'est les
salariés
c'est bien entendu les actionnaires
c'est la municipalité c'est la région
il faut que notre gouvernement mais
aussi au niveau de la Communauté
européenne etc
je dirais dans un monde idéal dès le
premier janvier 2023 il décide
qu'effectivement l'activité
économiquement responsable doit être en
harmonie avec les aspirations et les
besoins des trois ans qui viennent et là
moi parmi les 20
propositions de Gaëlle pour réformer le
capitalisme j'en ai une et je reconnais
que quand je vais le dire
j'apprécie la difficulté c'est de
différencier le coût du capital selon la
nature des exploitations le problème est
simple à dire il est extraordinairement
complexe à régler et ça ça doit être le
chantier de tout de suite
où je pourrais vous garder encore des
heures et des heures mais mais ça va
faire ça va faire long donc vous allez
être obligé de revenir alors Gaëlle tu
reviens au printemps c'est ça et donc il
va falloir qu'on se goupille un truc au
printemps pour faire l'épisode 2
on doit être combien là en ligne essaye
de m'attraper le chiffre on s'en fout
oui on est 12749
je vais vous demander à chacun trois
bouquins et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et le mot de la frein sera
pour Gilles
alors les bouquins je vais évidemment
parler des miens je suis désolé
je publie composé un monde en commun une
théologie politique de l'anthropocène au
seuil qui marche tellement bien qu'on
est en train de réimprimer déjà donc
merci au lecteur qui nous font confiance
voilà écoute 27 euros c'est un gros pavé
mais je crois que c'est voilà disons le
diagnostic et sous-jacent à ce bouquin
c'est la transition écologique c'est le
projet de société pour aujourd'hui et
demain mais on a besoin d'inventivité
institutionnelle de courage et les
ressources spirituelles sont des
patrimoines dans lesquels on peut puiser
pour avoir ce courage politique
institutionnel social d'inventer le
monde de demain dont on a besoin
deuxième livre qui est un livre en
italien que je publie également en ce
moment en italien qui s'appelle la
révolutionné Dolce de la transition
écologique voilà la révolution douce de
la transition écologique qui fait un
tabac également en Italie en ce moment
parce que vous savez que l'Italie a créé
un ministère de la transition écologique
qui ne fait pas grand chose mais les
Italiens ont compris parce qu'ils ont
manqué cet été que ça un enjeu
absolument central voilà le troisième
livre je recommanderais peut-être le
très beau livre de David Greber et David
vengro je ne sais plus comment il était
traduit en français mais ça doit être
quelque chose comme il était une fois et
c'est un livre d'anthropologue qui
réfléchit aux racines de la civilisation
humaine sur la planète livre très
discuté par les archéologues mais très
intéressant extrêmement subtil et et
jubilatoire parce que David Greber était
un grand écrivain malheureusement décédé
voilà donc je recommande celui-ci un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
tricher
donc je veux deux autres bouquins de
patois des autres bouquin n'est pas moi
volontiers un livre de Mark Welling qui
est un collègue d'Afrique du Sud sur la
transition vous trouverez facilement il
vient d'être publié il y a un an c'est
une espèce de synthèse de la commande la
pensée complexe au sens des sciences
politiques peut appréhender
la question de la transition énergétique
dans les pays du Sud
voilà et puis un troisième tu vas un
troisième livre je recommanderais quand
même aussi mais nos rapports de
l'Institut Rousseau c'est un livre
2% pour des degrés mais je l'ai déjà
cité alors un autre un rapport qu'on a
publié l'an dernier sur les banques
européennes ce qu'on a montré c'est que
les 11 premières banques de la zone euro
ont dans leur bilan tellement d'actifs
fossiles qu'elles savent que si on
allait très très vite aujourd'hui au
niveau de la transition et qu'on
bannissait les trois hydrocarbures
fossiles charbon pétrole gaz elle serait
tout en faillite parce que ces actifs
financiers fossiles représentent 95% de
leur fonds propres dont on parlait tout
à l'heure un conseil pour les jeunes
générations un conseil pour les jeunes
générations pour lutter contre la
tentation de la déprime aller travailler
dans des communautés de type éco campus
echo village avec vos mains ce qu'on
fait par exemple dans le social habitat
de l'Université de stellenbos en Afrique
du Sud avant d'entrer en classe on va
tous faire de la permaculture dans le
jardin des profs et les étudiants
ensemble donc moi je vais faire de la
perma avec mes étudiants ensuite on va
en classe ça crée évidemment à une pas
faire pédagogique unique au monde et
ensuite on mange on est tous végétariens
et on mange des produits du jardin qu'on
a cultivé
Raphaël trois bouquins un conseil pour
les jeunes générations alors comme comme
Gaël a trichit tu as le droit de me
citer ton bouquin
donc ça fera ton bouquin plus 3 autres
absolument
écoute j'ai la joie effectivement de
publier mon deuxième essai tu veux que
je montre et je veux que tu montres
surtout que la
elle est jolie pas la photo du mec mais
c'est demain la fin de l'insouciance
enfin le titre c'est demain le
sous-titre la fin de l'insouciance et je
dois il faut que j'écrive au château à
l'Élysée parce qu'il m'a piqué ma phrase
mais bon mais c'est ma première phrase
c'est effectivement la fin de
l'insouciance
effectivement on est en réédition
apparemment c'est ça ça a bien démarré
et l'idée et l'idée c'est que
effectivement demain ne peut
s'appréhender alors moi j'ai le tropisme
de l'entreprise
mais il faut tout faire pour qu'il n'y
ait pas ce que je qualifie de décrochage
humain de portance humaine voilà on vole
grâce à la portion humaine le premier
livre que je recommande c'est celui de
Francis lucuyama que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure de la fin de l'histoire parce
que je crois que c'est en comprenant
la la conscience
c'est pas la conscience la certitude
voilà qu'effectivement en 92 avec la
chute du mur où j'ai eu la chance d'être
le lendemain du ou le mur a commencé à
craquer
c'est la certitude qu'il n'y avait plus
de conflits idéologique qui permettait
en fait au néolibéralisme je reprends
ton terme de poste libéralisme d'être
dominant le deuxième c'est un tout petit
bouquin qui se lit en trois quarts
d'heure je crois que je vous l'avais
déjà donné mais parce que je l'adore
c'est le petit traité de la servitude
volontaire de la Boétie c'est il faut
être effectivement conscient
que nous sommes plus ou moins tous dans
cette servitude
volontaire le troisième qui me venait à
la tête j'ai un vrai problème de mémoire
avec les titres c'est l'âge absolument
mais je l'ai adoré c'est vous allez le
retrouver c'est un assez gros pavé sur
les mémoires de
du fils de Christophe Colomb
qui avait l'idée de de créer une
bibliothèque du savoir alors pourquoi je
dis ça c'est que
et puisque tu vas non tu vas tu vas
accorder je crois que c'était ça la
banque ou effectivement il avait eu
c'est l'histoire d'une bibliothèque
engloutie
la bibliothèque engloutie voilà c'est ça
mais absolument absolument passionnant
et de voir
parce que je travaille là sur quelques
start-up et l'une d'elles sur comment
préserver tout le savoir tacite de
l'oralité
j'aurai l'occasion peut-être de revenir
là-dessus et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations alors le conseil pour les
jeunes générations moi c'est
effectivement de choses la première je
je reviens sur ce que j'ai dû dire une
première fois
dès lors que vous êtes fiable vous
protéger votre futur
la fiabilité et votre garantie
et le deuxième élément faites du
bénévolat
et alors moi je prêche pour celui que je
vends mais aller au devant de gens qui
sont dans la souffrance
vous permettent en leur apportant de
l'aide et de l'assistance de vous
ressourcez-vous même et d'affronter les
moments difficiles qui vont venir Gilles
trois bouquins et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations alors comme ils ont
tous les deux gruger tu as le droit de
caserne tes bouquins si tu as envie
moi comme je suis un vrai un vrai
protestant je peux pas me laisser aller
à ce genre de
manœuvre typique des protestants
de type cardiaque alors les livres donc
des livres vraiment assez courts lisible
Bernard Marie
souriez vous êtes français ou justement
il explique que la vraie liberté c'est
la sécurité sociale c'est une
compilation de chroniques radio qu'il a
faite pour France Inter donc c'est
vraiment court vraiment lisible
évidemment vers la Marie si on peut on
peut un peu tout lire
un deuxième livre ça serait jean-gadret
qui est un vieux monsieur qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup
formé indirectement comme économiste par
ses livres un grand monsieur un grand
grand monsieur qui devrait être beaucoup
plus connu
donc j'en garderai adieu à la croissance
donc j'explique en deux mots c'est un
vrai livre d'économiste j'en garderai
était à mathématicien statisticien qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la question des
services il a très vite compris avant
les autres que ma grande majorité des
emplois étaient dans les services il a
été écologiste avant tout le monde dans
la profession qu'il est toujours pas
évidemment il a été féministe avant tout
le monde dans la profession il a fait
des centaines d'articles sur son blog
sur alternative économique qui sont très
très bons qui datent de quelques années
que vous pouvez toujours lire donc adieu
à la croissance et fantastique et
un troisième livre ça plutôt deux livres
il y a une très belle collection de
livres récents à l'éditeur Tana le nom
de la collection s'appelle vraie ou fake
j'en ai dû lu deux récemment qui sont
vraiment excellent un sur l'énergie de
Maxime Cordiez et un autre qui
s'intitule relocalisé c'est des livres
extraordinairement bien fait très clairs
très facile à lire avec plein de petits
messages ils sont jolis enfin voilà et
on apprend plein plein de choses dans un
langage très très clair un conseil pour
les jeunes générations alors je ferai un
conseil un peu double face c'est d'abord
je leur disais je leur dirai
effectivement c'est un peu dans votre
sens pour réussir de la société
Soyez de droite
écoutez les vieux cons donc respecter
les normes de langage vestimentaire etc
il faut pour rentrer dans la société il
faut un moment il faut se soumettre et
sur se soumet pas on rentre jamais on
l'a tous fait c'est triste mais dans
toutes les communautés
aussi enfin bon voilà mais c'est mon
conseil c'est mon conseil donc je suis
de plus en plus de droite en
vieillissant inévitable donc soyez de
droite et en même temps et en même temps
si en tout cas vous venez d'un milieu
plutôt favorisé aisé engueuler vos
parents je pensais très important que
vous enlevez vos parents et que vous les
mettiez face à leur responsabilité parce
que ils ont beaucoup plus les déjà dit
tout à l'heure de capacité d'agir je
trouve que c'est insupportable je le dis
très clairement c'est insupportable ce
discours quand on dit c'est pas aux
jeunes qui sont précarisés qui sont
terrorisés dans tous les sens du terme
de construire le monde de demain
c'est-à-dire fatalement biologiquement
bien sûr que oui mais ils peuvent rien
faire les pauvres ils sont en panique
ils sont en galère et ceux qui peuvent
agir c'est beaucoup plus les gens qui
ont 40 ou 50 ans qui passent beaucoup de
temps à s'amuser avec de la thune et
donc voilà donc je dirais aux jeunes
écouter les vieux cons et engueuler vos
parents messieurs je voulais vous
remercier d'être venu un dimanche
on s'est régalé et je vous dis au
printemps excellente soirée merci
beaucoup
[Musique]